hey this is Andrew ground from exam pro
and cloud computing has now become one
of the essential skills that you need to
learn in order to make it in the web
develop industry in AWS Amazon Web
Services is the most popular cloud
computing service used by startups so
this whole course is about getting AWS
certified for the certified cloud
petitioner which is the entry level
certification and the idea here is that
by getting the certification you are
going to be able to prove that you can
work with cloud computing prove that you
can work with AWS you're gonna have a
lot more job opportunities available to
you so you know let's get to this and
start learning about AWS hey this is
Andrew Brown from exam pro and I'm gonna
try to answer all the questions you
might have about the CCP which is known
as the certified cloud practitioner to
determine whether it's the right
certification for you okay so the CCP is
all about a DuBose foundational
knowledge so what that means is that it
can show that you know how to poke
around and you can use the intimus
console and you know the general
offerings from AWS it's like a lite
version of the solution architect
associate okay but the CCP has some very
unique offerings which no other
certification on aid abuse has which is
they have a strong focus on billing and
business centric concepts okay and
that's why it's gonna make a lot of
sense why a lot of people who try to
obtain the CCP are in sales and
management because it's gonna give them
that knowledge to help them inform VPS
or CEOs the reasons why to use AWS okay
all right so the next thing you're
probably gonna ask me is what value does
the CCP hold well it's not a gilded
title
it can help superficially increase your
Abra's certification count if that's
something that some companies care about
but it's not recognized as an important
certification for developers on resume
so if you think by getting the CCP it's
gonna help you get a job it probably
won't help too much if you were a
bootcamp grad then it could be a good
indicator that you're a little bit
familiar with AWS so it can be ok in
that one circumstance but generally for
developers it's not going to help you
too
much all right so maybe you're thinking
so far hey Andrew this doesn't sound
that great why would I want to even
bother getting this and you might be
thinking about skipping the CCP but I'm
gonna tell you that that is not what you
should do you should actually go get the
CCP and why is that well it's for a
totally different reason it's because
the CCP is going to help you build
confidence and it's a very easy win
because it's the easy certification
because it's the most inexpensive
certification it's the perfect
opportunity for you to get comfortable
for when you actually go take a real
exam okay so the other exams the
associates and everything beyond that
are very difficult and you don't want
that to be your first certification you
go for because you're gonna go to the
exam center you're gonna be very nervous
or stressed out or something's gonna go
wrong and so by taking the CCP and going
to the test center you're going to learn
your test center and learn how you have
to be on time and the what the
environments gonna be like okay and that
is the big value out of the CCP so
that's why I want you to go after it and
also just some people they just prepare
because they might get overwhelmed once
they start with the solution architect
associate and so it is a very easy way
to ease into the associate
certifications all right so let's talk
about study time how much time do I have
to put in to pass this exam now if you
are a developer so you're already
working in industry you can pass this in
less than a week if you're a bootcamp
grad I'd say about 15 hours so we're
talking about a week and a half of study
and if you're in sales and management
you probably don't have a lot of
developer experience or with a cloud
infrastructure so we're looking at 20
hours of study but the thing is is that
you can you know book this exam a week
ahead and use this course and you will
pass because it is a very easy
certification and it's not a huge time
requirement okay so that just gives you
kind of an idea the time you need to put
in all right so when it comes time to
take this exam you're gonna have to go
to a test center which is partnered with
AWS and there are two test center
networks we have psi and Pearson VUE and
so
before the only way you could take this
exam you had to go in person to a test
center but now that Pearson VUE is part
of AWS as its offering the exams through
their network a Pearson VUE is known for
their proctored exams so what does the
proctor exam that's when you have
someone that is supervising or
monitoring your examination and
specifically for online okay so what
that means is that you can sign up and
schedule an online exam and through a
web camera and if you you would just
take the exam and somebody would watch
you to make sure that you're not
cheating okay so now it's even easier to
get into certified because you can take
this at the convenience of your own home
but I would strongly recommend that you
take it at an in-person test center if
there is one nearby just because when
you go for those harder certifications
they may not offer proctored exams and
so at this point I recommend that you
try to go to a test center but if you
just want to get even certified and
you're really excited definitely go take
it online all right and now we just have
some remaining questions here so what
does it cost to take this exam it's $100
USD it is the most inexpensive aid of a
certification it's going to take 90
minutes that's the time that you're
allocated during the the exam it doesn't
actually take that long you could
probably get it done in under an hour
again it's not a very hard certification
but I do recommend that when you go to
the exam you maximize all of your time
and review your questions because it is
a very good habit to get into when you
take exams there are 65 questions the
passing score is 70% I think that
actually is a hard number with all the
other exams it's kind of a floating
number so it's never exactly that amount
but I'm pretty sure for the cloud
practitioner if you get over 70% you are
going to pass okay and then when you get
the certification it's gonna be valid
for three years so it's gonna be with
you for quite a long time so there you
go hopefully that answers all the
questions you have about the certified
cloud practitioner
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and here I have the exam guide pulled up
because I'm gonna give you a quick
walkthrough of it so you have an idea
what AWS wants you to know in order to
pass this exam so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to scroll
long down to the content outline and
just give the domains a read and
understand the weighting of the actual
exam so we have four domains here we
have cloud concepts security technology
and billing and pricing and so the
largest portion of exam is technology at
36% and billing and pricing is the
lowest amount which is kind of funny
because I find that the most valuable
thing in the entire course is billing
and pricing okay we're gonna learn a lot
about billing and pricing AWS here but
that's just how they waited it but let's
just talk about these four domains so we
understand what it is that we need to
know for each of these domains so for
domain one we need we need to be able to
define the intimus cloud and its value
proposition we need to be able to
identify aspects of Ava's cloud
economics well this is the different
cloud architecture design principles
okay now for security we need to know a
variety of different database security
services and we need to know the shared
responsibility model okay you need to
know that for every single exam it's
always broaden up like a hundred times
over but yeah that's part of the
security donate on to technology you're
going to need to know all the core eight
of the services and also a bunch of
other eight of those services and you're
gonna need to know global infrastructure
okay so we're talking regions AZ's and
edge locations alright and then on to
billing and pricing so we need to be
able to compare and contrast various
pricing models for AWS recognize the
various account structures in relation
to Avis billing and pricing and identify
resources available for billing support
so that is the content outline so the
next thing I wanted to go over with you
is the response type so when you're
taking an exam you're gonna be presented
questions in one or the other format so
we have multiple choice and multiple
responsible for multiple choice you just
choose one out of four
okay and then for a multiple response
it's going to be two or more correct
responses out of five or more options
okay but generally I find that it's 2
out of 5 or 3 out of 6 okay and then the
last thing here is white papers so white
papers are generally core to studying
for AWS for the CCP however you do not
have to read a single white paper
everything in this course covers
anything that could possibly pop up in
these white papers here and white papers
are super boring okay but just so you
know we have the overview of Amazon Web
Services architecting for the cloud
eight of its best practices how eight of
us pricing works costs management in the
in AWS cloud okay so those are your four
white papers recommended and then a
fifth one this isn't a white paper
though but they just say compare the
eight of the support plans so you go to
the web page and you read about the
support plans okay so there you go that
is the exam guide in a nutshell
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at what is cloud
computing which is the most important
question on our journey to become a
certified cloud practitioner so what
I've done here is I pulled up the
textbook definition of cloud computing
and we will read through this and then I
will give you a bit more context on what
is cloud computing so cloud computing
from the dictionary is the practice of
using a network of remote servers hosted
on the internet to store manage and
process data rather than a local server
or personal computer okay so what does
that mean well to really understand that
we need to understand on-premise and
cloud providers so now most people are
using cloud providers such as AWS GCP or
as ER to run their actual workloads and
prior to that everyone was doing
on-premise so what will you do with
on-premise is you would own the servers
so that be the hardware and the software
you'd hire the IT people to configure
those servers and those applications
you'd pay or rent at the real estate to
house all these physical servers and you
would take all the risk now on premise
is still well and alive today and
there's definitely good reasons to have
an on-premise solution but a lot of
companies are now starting to use cloud
providers and so cloud providers are
like AWS GCP and Azure as I said earlier
and so here it's someone else owns the
servers so you are not responsible for
that hardware and to different degrees
they will configure the the software
layer for you or you have control over
it yourself depends on what kind of
service you are using they're hiring the
IT people and they're watching these
servers around the clock for you so you
do not have to pay for that and someone
else is paying for or renting the real
estate so they are buying the real
estate to house these servers which are
data centers and now you have a shared
responsibility so you're responsible for
configuring cloud services and the code
that you deploy on to these services and
so these cloud providers are going to
take care of the rest for you okay so
that is generally what cloud computing
is hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
pro and we are looking at these six
advantages and benefits of cloud
computing and so this section really is
about why go with a cloud provider over
on-premise okay and so let's jump into
the first point here so we have trade
capital expense for variable expense so
with on-prem you would have to pay for
your data centers and the servers and so
that would be an upfront cost where with
a cloud provider you're paying on-demand
so you only pay when you consume those
computing resources and pretty much
nothing else okay moving on to number 2
we have benefit from massive economics
of scale so when you're using cloud
computing you have usage from hundreds
of thousands of customers aggregated in
the cloud and so you are sharing the
cost with other customers to get
unbeatable savings which you cannot get
on Prem the next point here is stop
guessing capacity so eliminate guesswork
about infrastructure capacities so
instead of paying for idle or
underutilized servers you can scale up
or down to meet the current needs
so we're on Prem you would just buy your
servers and they would either be
underutilized because it would just be
way too big for the job or they're just
not being utilized all the time so
moving on to number four increased speed
and agility so with cloud computing you
can launch resources within a few clicks
within minutes instead of waiting days
or weeks for your IT to implement the
solution on Prem then number five we
have stopped spending money on running
and maintaining data centers so the idea
here is that if you don't have to pay
for the servers the IT staff and a bunch
of other stuff then you can just focus
on your customers okay so rather than
that heavy lifting of racking stacking
and powering servers and the last point
here is go global in minutes so deploy
your app in multi multiple regions
around the world with a with a few
clicks provide low latency and a better
experience for your customers at minimal
costs and so when you have an on-prem
environment that data center is I don't
know how many people can afford multiple
data centers but with AWS and cloud
computing you're gonna have a lot more
reach okay so those are the six
advantages and benefits of cloud
computing and this definitely shows up
on the exam so you do need to know these
six points
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the types of cloud
computing we have three here for us so
we have software as a service platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service and you can see that we have
this nice pyramid here I promise you
it's not a scheme it's just a way of
showing how one is built on top of
another okay
so starting at the top here we have
software's the service also known as SAS
and these are for customers okay so the
idea is that you have a completed
product that that is run and managed by
the service provider so you don't have
to worry about how the service is
maintained it just works and remains
available so if we had some examples of
sasses here maybe you'd have your Gmail
or your office
sixty-five or your Salesforce okay going
down to platform-as-a-service this is
really intended for developers it
removes the need for your organization
to manage the underlying infrastructure
and focus on the deployment and
management of your applications so the
idea here is you don't have to worry
about provisioning configuring and
understanding the hardware or less it
just works so you have an app you push
it so for AWS you have elastic beanstalk
then there's also Heroku which is a very
popular service and then I believe
there's one called like engines for
Google and then the last one on our list
here is infrastructure service and this
is really intended for admins and so
when you're using AWS GCP or asher this
is what infrastructure as a service is
so it's the basic building blocks for
cloud IT so it provides access to
networking features computers and data
storage space so you don't worry about
the IT staff the data centers or the
hardware but you have access to all
those resources to build whatever you
want okay and so obviously a if you
wanted to build your own platform as a
service you'd build it up on top of an
infrastructure service if you wanted to
build your own software the service you
can build that on top of the platform as
a service or an infrastructure as a
service so there you go hey this is
Angie Brown from exam pro and we are
looking at cloud computing deployment
models so there are three different
kinds here and so we're gonna start with
cloud on the left hand side work on two
on Prem and then talk about hybrid so
cloud is where you are fully utilizing
cloud computing so here I have a few
services such as Squarespace Basecamp
and Dropbox and it is very well-suited
for startups because it's extremely low
cost it's great for SAS offerings where
with on-prem or hybrid they might never
get to the size where they need to deal
with a regulatory bodies or explore it's
just the nature of the applications are
not that complicated or if it's new
projects or companies they don't have
red tape because they have existing
infrastructure ok and they can design to
be a hundred percent on cloud so now
going on to on-prem so on-prem is when
you are deploying resources on
using virtualization and resource
management tools and is sometimes called
private cloud and so on Prem is still
being utilized by a lot of companies
today and generally you will see public
sector so the government has on Prem
data centers when you're dealing with
super sensitive data such as possible so
you have like health records there is an
aversion to putting that into the cloud
or you have large enterprises with heavy
regulation so insurance companies and I
mean these organizations are starting to
soften and start utilizing cloud but
there are still holdouts and reasons
both technical and and business or
political reasons as to why you cannot
use cloud okay then you have hybrid and
so hybrid is where you use a combination
of both cloud on Prem so you connect the
two with hybrid services and so we see a
lot of banks using this we see FinTech
or investment management or even large
professional service providers and a lot
of the reasons why is that they can
adopt cloud but they have legacy
on-premise environments or some of their
customers or clients so still are not
comfortable with cloud computing so in
some capacity they are using a cloud but
it's totally possible that if they
started from day one they would just
only use cloud so there you could say I
have cibc which is a bank then you have
the CPP Investment Board that's a
Investment Board in Canada and you have
Deloitte which is a large professional
service so those are the three cloud
computing employment models hey this is
Andrew Brown from exam Pro and we are
looking at Ava's global infrastructure
and what we're going to figure out here
is where does all this cloud computing
stuff run okay so we have 69 AZ's within
22 geographical regions around the world
and we have lots of edge locations more
than available AZ's but what does that
all mean so eight of us serves over a
million active customers in more than
190 countries and they're steadily
expanding their global
structure to help customers achieve low
latency and higher throughput and so
that global infrastructure our region's
AZ's and edge location so a region is
just a physical location in the world
with multiple AZ's an AZ is one or more
discrete data centers owned by AWS and
then edge locations or data center it's
owned by a trusted partner of AWS and
may be owned by AWS themselves and so
now that we have that overview we're
gonna jump into those three types of
infrastructure hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and we are looking at
regions for the ADA blobel
infrastructure and so a region is a
geographically distinct location which
has multiple data centers also known as
a Z's for AWS and I've highlighted in
red geographically a distinct because
that is the most important thing you
need to remember about regions every
region is physically isolated from an
independent of every other region in
terms of location power and water supply
every region has at least two AZ so
again an AZ is a data center so it has
at least two data centers running within
that region the largest region for AWS
is us East so that is north of Virginia
and new services almost always become
available first in u.s. East and not all
services are available in all regions
okay so if you definitely want to use a
new feature or service via AWS your best
bet is to switch over to US East and
u.s. East one which again is north
Virginia is the region where you see all
your billing information all right and
you can just see here on the left-hand
side I have a bunch of flags for the
countries where these regions are run in
here I might not have all of them in
here but I definitely have a lot here so
you can see there's a lot of coverage
here so now that we know what a region
is let's just go take a look at some of
the features of a region's okay so I
just hopped over to the AWS website
because I just wanted to show you a
little bit more about regions visually
and so here we have they say region maps
but these are really just a particular
continents that house a bunch of regions
so looking at north
America you can see we have regions on
the west coast and the East Coast and so
we have Ohio or Oregon North California
and we have Canada and North Virginia
here okay and so you can see in Canada
there's only two availability zones and
they are working on third one it was
just recently announced so either Bess
can always say that they at least have
two AZ's in every single region but
they're definitely coming close to being
able to say they have at least three in
every region which is very important
because most companies or enterprises
have to run in at least three AZ's so
now going on to South America you can
see that there is a single region here
and that is in Brazil and then we have
over here in Europe so we have a few
here we have London Stockholm Frankfurt
Paris and brought him and sorry if I
pronounced that wrong I've forgotten
already
oh and then we have Ireland okay sorry
Ireland I know you're you're there as
well okay and then on to Asia Pacific so
we have mainland China Sydney so I would
think that that would be Australia there
Tokyo that's Japan Seoul so that is
Korea cannot say that but that's another
place in mainland China and we have
another place in Japan and then Mumbai
so I believe that is India and then we
have Hongkong so that's Hong Kong okay
so yeah those are the regions and then
if we just hop over here to the regional
table this gives you an idea what
services are offered so when we said
that not all services are available you
can kind of see that like for example
that Amazon Connect is only available in
a few regions so we have North Virginia
and North Carolina okay and then deep
blends really is only in Northern
Virginia so again well as I said
everything is north Northern Virginia
you can see we have checkboxes all the
way down here and this is also broken up
based on those geographical continents
so if I go here you can see Ireland
seems to be having all the ones in
Europe and then in Asia Pacific it looks
like I guess in a poor so the poor looks
like they have the majority of services
there okay
so there you go that
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at availability zones
also known as a Z's so an AZ is a data
center owned and operated by AWS in
which eight of us services run each
region has at least two a Z's and ADA
bus is getting pretty close to being
able to say that they have at least
three a Z's in all regions these are
represented by a region code followed by
a letter identifier so US East one is
region that would be North Virginia and
a is the data center okay and so from
North Virginia there are six AZ's so
you'd have ABCDE F okay then we want to
just talk on the concept of multi KZ so
this is when you're distributing your
instances across a multiple availability
zones which allows for failover
configuration for handling requests when
one a Z goes down okay so that is very
useful and then one more thing we want
to note is that the latency between
availability zones is sub ten
milliseconds okay so there these AZ's
are purposely positioned to be exactly
that far apart okay and so there you go
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at edge locations and
this is all about getting data fast or
uploading it a fast to AWS so an edge
location is a data center owned by a
trusted partner of AWS which has a
direct connection to the ADA based
network these locations serve requests
for a cloud front and ruffle v3 and
requests going to either of these
services will be routed to the nearest
edge location automatically so we also
have s3 transfer acceleration and API a
gateway and the idea here is that this
is where you want to upload data quickly
to AWS you're going to use these two
services to hit a special endpoint at an
edge location to then transfer stuff
quickly via the ADA based network okay
so the whole takeaway from this is that
edge locations allow for low latency no
matter where the end user is
geographically located all right so
we're back on the AWS web
site here where we were looking at
regions earlier but this time I want to
give attention to edge locations so edge
locations are the little blue dots here
and you can see there are a lot of them
okay and so down below we have an idea
of how many education there are you can
see that there are a lot so even just in
Atlanta alone there are five and so they
definitely outnumber availability zones
okay so just to give you an idea those
are the ones for North America then down
below we have just a few there okay for
Brazil then in Europe we have quite a
few here and then in asia-pacific we
have more education so there you go
that's education hey this is Andrew
Brown from exam pro and we're gonna take
a look at gov cloud okay and so gov
cloud is a very special region that
allows customers to have sensitive
controlled unclassified information and
other types of regulated workloads so
the gov cloud region is only operated by
employees who are US citizens and us or
on US soil so it's definitely not
something that I can use because you
have to be a u.s. identity and root
account holders who pass a screening
process in order to use this particular
region so who is this very special
region for it's for customers that need
to architect secure cloud solutions that
comply with federal the Department of
Justice the u.s. international traffic
in arms regulation export administration
regulations and the Department of
Defense okay so it just makes it a lot
easier if you are working in the US with
these government bodies in order to
utilize cloud computing okay so I just
hop back over here on the 8th of this
global infrastructure regions page
because I just wanted to highlight here
those gov cloud regions so there
actually are two there is one on US west
and US East as far as I'm aware of there
aren't any other gov clouds other than
for us at this time maybe in the future
eight of us will have it for other
countries but for the time being it's
just the US and just to look at the gov
Paige here in more detailed here you can
see all the nice graphics here for that
address security and compliance so if
you want to build something and sell it
to the government or government related
industries by using gov cloud you were
going to become compliant okay and
that's gonna make business a lot easier
for you so yeah that's all you need to
know hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
pro and I'm gonna show you how to get
set up with your a to this account so
here I am on the AWS home page and we
have two buttons that we can click on
click the one here in the middle or
click the big orange button to create
our account I like to press the orange
one so that's what I'm gonna go ahead
and do here okay okay great and so now
we're gonna be presented with a form
here so I'm going to go ahead here and
just fill in an email so I'm gonna do
Andrew plus fresh at exam proko since
this is a fresh account okay and I'm
just going to supply some kind of
password here I'm going to call this the
exam pro a fresh account okay and I'm
just going to go ahead here and continue
so now in order to create this account
we're going to have to provide some
additional information here so I'm just
going to mark this as a personal and I'm
going to fill in this information here
okay so I'm just gonna have to go here
and fill that in okay okay so now I have
that information filled in there and so
I'm just gonna have to check here to say
that I agree to their customer agreement
okay and we can go ahead and create our
account now in order to use AWS you have
to have a valid credit card you cannot
use any of us without a credit card okay
so that's just something that you're
going to have to do so I'm gonna just go
ahead here and provide my credit card
here okay alright so now I have all my
information filled in here so I'm just
going to go ahead and verify and add
okay and then now it just wants to also
verify on my phone number this is
definitely something that's required so
I'm just going to provide my phone
number here okay great my phone numbers
in there I'm just going to supply the
security check here so we'll just fill
that in okay and then we will just send
an SMS and confirm great so that text
message came in here so I'm just going
to fill in the confirmation here zero
four four eight okay and great so now
we're verified okay so now we are going
to choose our support plan we're
definitely going to go with the basic
here great and so now we just have a
little bit of information here I don't
really need to do any of this I'm just
ready to go sign in to the console great
so now that we've created our account I
believe we could probably go ahead and
sign up here I'm not sure if we have to
confirm our email because we did confirm
by phone number but let's just give it a
go here and see if we can log-in okay so
we'll just put that in there I'll just
provide the password
great so we have made it into this
atypical account here so this new
account is realized so there you go
and maybe we'll just have to poke around
here to see if there's anything else we
need to do but yeah we're in good shape
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and what we're going to do now is make
sure you do not get over build and there
are three ways we're going to do that so
there are some billing preferences we're
going to set we're gonna set up a budget
in a Bizet sand we're also gonna create
a building alarm okay I'm just gonna
talk you also through as to like the
advantages and disadvantages of some of
these things and also just make sure we
do not get over build within our account
so the first thing I want you to do is I
want you to make your way over to
support or sorry maybe under your
account here you're gonna go to my
billing dashboard and when you get over
here I want you to click on the left
hand side here and go to billing
preferences okay and so we're gonna have
a bunch of preferences here and they're
all really good so the first one is
receive a PDF invoice by email I would
check that on receive free tier usage
alerts this is definitely important
because if you have a free account you
want to know when you are going outside
that free tier and so then you just
provide your email there so I'm just
gonna do Andrew plus fresh at exam Pro
taco there and then we have received
billing alerts okay and you definitely
want to turn that on and there is this
detail billing reports down here this is
a legacy feature this has now been
replaced with cost and usage reports
okay so it's not necessary to turn that
on and actually do show you how to use
cost and usage somewhere in this course
here so we will cover that but anyway
make sure these are all three ticked on
it provides your email and save your
preferences okay and now you're going to
be in the loop of some of your billing
information okay so now that we have
these preferences set up let's make our
way over to eight of us budgets so I
want you to go to the top here and we're
going to type in budgets okay and so
what budgets do is they allow you to
tell you whether you are
getting over or whether you are going
over your defined budget or it's going
to also provide some forecast costs to
you as well okay so now that Atos
budgets here has loaded what I want you
to do is create a new budget you get two
free budgets in AWS so we can definitely
set two there it's two cents per day for
budgets and so that doesn't sound like a
lot but if you made your third budget
it's gonna cost you $14 per month okay
so form more additional ways of tracking
cost we're gonna use billion lines which
really are inexpensive or and or free
but we'll do budgets first because it's
good to at least have one budget set
here for all costs so here I'm just
gonna say overall costs okay all right
and we will leave it monthly here I
can't remember if overall is one or two
L's I think it's two if we want this to
be a reoccurring budget we're gonna have
a fixed cost and we're gonna set it
something something very low such as
$20.00 okay since we are using again the
free tier we should not be expecting to
see a bill for quite a while and $20.00
is a good low bill there and we
definitely want all costs unblended so
this is great and everything is checkbox
there so we'll go ahead here and
configure alerts and we're going to
provide our email again so you Andrew
plus fresh at exam proko okay and we'll
just it out there it's already been
added you could also use SNS but we're
gonna leave that alone and we can also
get alerted when we are approaching it
so we haven't surpassed a hundred
percent but actually I'm just gonna set
it to 100 because $20 to me is not a lot
and we can do this for actual or
forecasted I'm gonna leave that for
actual okay and I'm gonna go ahead there
and create that budget all right and so
we don't have the information here but
if I just give it a hard refresh so if
you are if you are using an account
where you're doing stuff if you do
refresh there you'll probably see more
information okay great so we've created
a budget so now that we have our budget
created there let's go make a billion
LARM for a higher amount okay so what I
want you to do is go to services and
type in cloud watch okay and once we are
over here we are going to make our way
over to alarms all right and so we're
gonna make our way over to a billing
here and what it's gonna tell us is that
we need to switch regions because
billing metrics always live in u.s. East
one okay so generally it's always good
to switch to that region there so what
we'll do is we'll go up to the top here
and switch to you as East one okay and
so now if we go to billing we can now
set our billing alarm okay so notice
down here that we get ten free alarms
and a thousand free email notification
so it's definitely a more free than
budgets okay but budgets it does have a
lot more functionality there but you can
use definitely use both okay so here I'm
creating a new billing alarm and I'm
just going to scroll down here and we
can set the amount so here I'm just
gonna set a larger amount such as $100
and so if it's greater or equal to that
then it is going to alert me okay and we
leave Kat and estimated charges there
alone we'll look at some additional
configuration this is all good we'll hit
next okay and then the next thing is we
need it to actually notify us so we're
going to say add notification here and
oh I think I already had one here so
it's not necessary but we needed to send
it to something so it's going to need an
SNS topic we don't have one so we'll
create a new one
okay and we call this notify me okay and
then I'll just provide my email there
again okay and we will hit create topic
and then we'll go ahead and hit next and
we'll just say so this $100 hundred
built a hundred building alarm I don't
know for all that you do spaces there so
I'm just out of habit I always leave out
spaces great and so we're just
previewing it here so we'll just scroll
down this all looks good and so now we
have a billion LARM so you know it's not
uncommon to create multiple building
alarms so you could have one at 100 and
then 150 and 200 just so you can keep
track of that stuff
and of course you definitely want to
make use of Intimus budgets so you have
to there that you can utilize so maybe
once you start using your account and
you use the live you see two instances
you just want to monitor that you create
a budget for that but yeah we have all
bases covered here and the only thing
that is left to do is we need to confirm
this the email that was sent out to us
so that our billing alarm it will take
effect okay all right so that
notification was sent to me for the
billing alarm therefore notify me so
it's just me subscribing to that SMS
topic I guess we only have to do this
once and I think we add additional ones
we won't have to confirm but I'm just
gonna go ahead here and hit confirmation
okay and so now that is confirmed there
okay and I think if I do a refresh here
it should say that this is now a
different state okay so just has nothing
there which is good so yeah we are all
set up and we don't have to worry about
get me what we're build all right so
there's a little bit more work we need
to do to have our account fully set up
so we can start working with AWS and
what I want you to do is make your way
over to I am so just go up here and type
in I am if you click that there you will
end up in the same place that I am here
and so we have a bunch of
recommendations here the abus wants us
to do so we need to turn MFA on our root
account we need to create individual
users because we generally do not want
to be using the root account which is
what we're logged in as right now and
we'll have to set some groups and assign
permissions and apply anion password
policy so let's go ahead and do that but
just before we do I just want to make it
easier for us to sign in so what we can
do here is change this URL so just go
ahead here and customize and we're just
gonna say exam Pro fresh okay and that
is a unique name so if you type in
something and it says it's not or it's
taken just have to change it until you
get something that you like so now that
we have that set up let's go turn on MFA
so we're going to want to turn on mfa
for this account specifically the root
account here and the reason why is that
let's say someone stole your email and
password to this root account then they
would be able to do some serious damage
so by turning on MFA there's going to be
an additional layer of securities so the
idea is when somebody logs in they're
gonna have to provide an additional code
based on the MFA delivery mechanism so
just let's go here and hit manage MFA
okay and so it's gonna pop up here and
just say what we're already doing which
is to start securing our account and so
I'm just going to click off there go to
MFA and activate MFA and so now we're
gonna be presented with three options we
have virtual you UTF and other hardware
so virtual is gonna be for mobile
devices that's what we're gonna do so
we're just gonna go ahead there and hit
continue okay and what we want to do is
we want to install a compatible
application on our phone so just going
over here if we scroll down it's going
to tell us which ones are compatible I
definitely know a thent occator is one
so I'm just going to search for that
there where are you yeah down here so if
you're on Android or iPhone you have off
b2 or Google Authenticator I'm using
Google Authenticator I find that more
easy to use and then the idea here is
you'll just hit show QR code and then
using once you have Authenticator
installed you're going to open up the
Authenticator app I know you can't see
me doing this so I'll just have to talk
my way through it here and there's a
plus button in Google Authenticator and
it says scan a barcode and so now I'm
holding my my phone up to the computer
there it's grabbed the code it's saved
the secret so now what I need to do is
enter in two consecutive codes so going
down here I'm gonna enter this code in
before it expires so this one is seven
eight six seven six three and then
there's a little wheel that is spinning
and it's going to then give us a new set
of numbers okay and so now it is now
nine eight four eight one six and so I'm
just going to hit a sign
hey there and now it mfa is turned on so
now that we have mfa turned on we can
make our way back to our dashboard and
proceed to the next step so now we're
going to proceed to create ourselves our
own user because again we do not want to
be using the root account this should be
a rarely used and we should just create
ourselves users so it will hit manage
users here we're going to hit add user
I'm going to create a new one called
Andrew Brown we're going to give it
pragmatic access and access to the
console we're going to let it auto
generate a password for us and we're
going to make sure that it requires a
password reset the next time this user
logs in going to permissions we don't
have any group so we're gonna create a
group here and we're gonna call this
group and admin or admins I should say
and we're going to give it administrator
access now generally you don't want to
be giving too many users admin access
because this gives you full access just
like a root account but for our purposes
here this is totally fine it's not
unusual to have one or two admins within
your entire account but generally you
want to set most people as power user ok
and this is a it gives you full access
but there are some limitations such as
you don't have the ability to manage
users and groups so power user is a very
good one here but for this one here we
are going to stick with admin I'm gonna
hit create group and we are gonna go
ahead and hit next and review and we
will hit create user and so now what it
will do is we're gonna get an access key
ID a secret and a password so I'm just
gonna expose those here and I'm just
gonna copy these off-screen alright and
then we will just proceed here ok so I
just copied at least my password
off-screen here and what I'm gonna do
next is I'm going to make my way back to
the iam console so we'll just go up here
services and we can just type in I am ok
and so now we have done pretty much
everything here except for setting a
password policy so
just before we go ahead and set a
password policy what I want to do is I
want to login to this new user so we
have this nice long URL here so I want
you to copy that URL and what we're
going to do is we're going to log out
and now we'll log in as that new user
okay so I'll just go ahead here and log
out great so I'm logged out here and so
the way we can get to that page is we
can paste in that URL up here which will
bring us to the console and so you can
you can always use that link or if you
can remember that alias you can always
just go to the console and type it in
there and so my name was Andrew Brown
here I'm just gonna go off screen and
grab my password and I'm just gonna hit
sign in here alright and so now I just
need to reset my password here so I'm
gonna provide the old password and we
were going to set a new password great
and so now I'm logged in not as the root
user but as a new user I've created and
just one more thing here I want to go
back to I am here and the reason I want
to go back here is that I exposed my
access key and password to you and
anytime that actually happens we're
gonna want to do is go to your user
there and I'm gonna go to Andrew Brown
here and we're gonna go to our security
credentials and you can see that was
that access key and you saw that
password so what I can do is I can make
it inactive and then I can create myself
another access key and I'm not going to
show you the secret this time around but
it's just you know any time you
accidentally share your credentials
you're definitely going to want to reset
them there and the password that you saw
earlier it doesn't matter because I
reset my password when I logged in here
okay so now that that is all setup what
we will do is we will log out of this
count and we will log back in as the
root account to set up a password policy
okay and I just want to show you when I
go to sign into the console it's going
to show me this filled in and so
whenever we're logging in as the root
account we actually have to click this
link down below and so we
just type in our email here but if I
wanted to log back in as that user I
could just type in here exam pro fresh
and it would bring me back to here and I
would fill in this information but if
you're always logging in as the root
user I'm just gonna click back there
it's always your email I know it's a
little bit confusing but that's just how
it works and so this time around I got
the MFA so I can't just log in
willy-nilly so I'm just gonna use my
phone and I'm going to open up a sent
occator and I have to provide it that
code okay so it's those numbers again so
this one's gonna be 9 0 4 3 6 1 I'm
gonna hit submit and so now I'm back
into my account and we'll make our way
back to I am and do that last stuff here
and so we just have one more thing that
AWS wants us to do and let's apply an IM
password policy so we'll go down here
and click manage password policy and so
what we can see is a bunch of stuff and
we really just care about this part up
here so I'll set password policy and now
we can see some rules so you can enforce
the minimum characters you can require
at least one uppercase one lowercase at
least one number require at least one of
these enable password expiration yeah I
could do that I suppose password
expiration requires that been reset
maybe not allow users to change their
own password definitely prevent password
reuse so ensure they don't use the same
password I would probably just crank
this up as high as possible we'll leave
it as five and we'll Save Changes and so
now if we go back to our dashboard we
should satisfy that entire list and so
we have so we've met every requirement
of AWS so generally from now on you
should just log in as that user and stay
out of your root account ok
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and now that we've set up our account I
want to go through the motions of using
some of the most common 8 of a services
with you here so you can gain some
confidence here on the platform itself
and just to have some practical hands-on
experience this is not going to be a
very difficult section it's not
important for you to remember anything
but just to again gain confidence and
just before we get started here I want
to make sure that you are in the North
Virginia region okay so North Virginia
also known as US East one the reason why
it's one is because there's another US
which is usc's - this one is used East
one because it came first but based on
the region you're in is going to change
the the offerings that you have because
not everything is available in every
single region generally they are across
all regions but like if I was in Canada
central we have a fewer availability
zones those are data centers where in
North Virginia we have like six and if
there are any new features they're
definitely gonna be in North Virginia so
I'm just gonna ask you to change over to
that region and follow along with me
there okay so the first thing I want you
to do is I'm gonna show you how to
launch a server so a server is good to
be using ec2 so going up to services
here we will type in ec2 and we'll make
our way over to the ec2 console so once
we are here I want you to go ahead and
launch a new instance so there's a big
blue button here so just hit launch
instance and now we're going to be
presented with a bunch of options to
configure our server so we are going to
choose what OS we want to use we're
going to stick with Amazon Linux -
because it's part of the free tier and
saving money is a great thing when we
are learning the next thing we need to
do is choose the size of our of our
server here so these are called instance
types and so you can see that the memory
gets larger in the amount of CPUs get
larger we're gonna stick with t2 micro
because again that's part of the free
tier and we want to save some money
going next to instance details we can
choose how many instances we want to
start an instance is a server
if you have a ten instances that's ten
servers and we have a lot of options
here we're going to launch it in our
default PPC and into the default subnet
it is going to be auto assign to a
public IP so it's going to be public
facing and we're going to once you
create an IM role here so what i want
you to do is go ahead and just right
click here and make a new tab because we
want to give this a bit of permissions
so up here i'm just going to go to of
the IM a management console and i want
you to make your way down and create a
new role and so we are going to be
presented with a bunch of options so we
are creating a role for you see - so
we'll select ec2 we're going to go to
next to permissions and i want you to
type in SSM and i want you to choose
Amazon ec2 role for SSM SSM is simple
systems manager and that's going to be a
way for us to actually log into that
machine okay and so we're gonna get here
and I'm just gonna say a my ec2 role and
I want you to hit create role and so now
that role has been created and we will
just go ahead and close that tab there
and we will drop this down you can see
that it says none so we'll hit the
refresh button here I will choose my ec2
role so now we have that that set up we
are going to leave everything else blank
and I want you to go to storage so here
you can choose how how much storage you
want it's gonna have 8 gigabytes by
default you change the volume type we're
gonna stick with general purpose and we
are going to go review and launch and we
were gonna hit launch and it's going to
ask you to create a key pair and so key
pairs are used to get into the server
but we actually don't need one because
we are using SSM which is another way of
logging in to the server so we're gonna
proceed without a key pair okay I'm
gonna set I acknowledge that I will not
be able connect to this instance unless
I already know the the built-in password
which is not true because we can get
through systems manager but we will go
ahead and launch this instance alright
and so this little instance is now
launching in order for us to see it you
can either go view instances we'll just
click that down below here alright and
so now this instance is launching and
you can see it
State and we're waiting for two status
checks to pass so this is gonna turn
from yellow to green and then we're
gonna wait for this to initialize and
once that's done here I'll see you here
in a moment go okay so after a short
wait here I think I waited about three
to four minutes our server is now
running and it also has two checks so
that means that the server is in good
shape so now that our server is running
we'll just go take a peek down here
because we get a variety of different
information such as when it was launched
the i.m roll the security group that is
in which was the default one what size
it was and we can see that it has a
public IP address and private IP
addresses okay so now that the server is
running this is costing us money now we
re on the free tier so I guess
technically it's not but if we wanted to
shut this down and we're not gonna shut
it down just yep I'm just showing here
that we would just go here to terminate
and that would shut this server down and
that we would no longer be paying for it
we could also stop the instance and that
wouldn't destroy it but it would have it
not run anymore and we'd also be saving
money okay so whether you stop or
terminate that instance will ensure that
you save money so now that this is done
let's actually learn how to get access
to this instance alright so there's a
couple different ways we can get into
this instance one way is using SSH so if
we had create that key pair we could use
it to get into that server here or we
can use a simple Systems Manager
sessions manager which is the my
preferred way and a bus AWS is
recommended way which is what we're
going to do but just before we go ahead
over to SSM I want you to right-click
here and just go to connect and you can
see that it's actually giving you
instructions so if you had downloaded
that key pair you would had a sham on it
you would have had to do a bunch of
other stuff so you'd have to use SSH and
provide that key to get into it so there
are instructions there there's also this
ec2 instance Connect and so this is
another way to connect I'm not sure if
it would let us in here without our our
key pair but I'll just give it a go here
and it did so this is one
this is actually guys the third way to
access it so actually I'm in the server
right now but the way I want to show you
how to get in is via simple Systems
Manager so I'm just going to go ahead
there and close that I want you to go to
the top here and type in SSM which is
for simple systems manager even though
they never display the simple word there
anymore it definitely is part of the
name and then once we are over here I
want you to go to the left hand side and
go to a session manager and we're going
to start a session and so we can see we
have our instance so remember when we
created that I am role and we set it
with that SSM UCT role that was so that
we could use sessions manager and the
advantage here of using sessions manager
it's going to log every time somebody
uses a session so I just hit start on
that session there and so it's very
similar to that other connect screen
here and it actually logs in as the root
user not the ec2 user which is a bit
frustrating so we'd have to do sudo su
ec2 - user and now we are the correct
user and we are within this instance so
you know that's how you gain access to
it we're not really going to be doing
much with this instance today so I want
you to go ahead and terminate this
instance we're sorry that session there
but that session history is recorded so
by forcing everyone to use sessions
manager you're gonna have a bit more
visibility over what's going on with
these machines whereas SSH might not
provide that same visibility without you
manually putting that effort in there
okay but we'll make our way back to the
ec2 console here so just type in ec2
here again and once we are here I want
you to go on the left hand side to
instances and so here we can see our
server so we now know how to get into
this machine and I would say that we
probably want to go ahead and stop this
instance here so I want you to go ahead
and just stop it okay and that way it's
not going to cost us anything and now we
can do our next tab which is to create
an AMI
all right so now we're gonna learn how
to create an ami and you can think of an
ami as like a snapshot or like saving a
copy of your entire server so what
you're gonna do is go up to the make
sure the instance is selected there go
to actions
we're gonna go to image here and create
an image now we could create an image
whether this is stopped or running if it
was terminated the server wouldn't exist
anymore so there would be nothing to
create an image of well we'll go ahead
here and create an image and we are
going to have to provide it some
information so I'm just gonna call this
fresh - 0 0 0 ok and then you can see
that it has an instance volume and so
that is the hard drive that's attached
there and we're just going to leave it
as the default settings and create an
image and so now it's creamed the image
and its view pending image creation so
we'll click on this blue link here and
we will just wait until that is created
now it doesn't take too long the idea
here is now once we have an ami if we
wanted to launch another copy of this
the server we were just gonna have to
hit launch here ok but the real reason I
wanted you to set up this ami was
because we are going to next set up an
auto scaling group and we're going to
need an ami to do that ok so I'll just
see you here in a little bit once this
is done and I just wanted to show you
here that it is done alright and so now
if we wanted to launch a version of the
server we could hit launch and it's
going to go to the second step so if we
go back here you can actually see that
it shows fresh 0 0 0 so if we were to
proceed through this it's a way for us
to upgrade our server or make other
changes to it or just so that we have a
copy of it so we can launch multiple
servers and just to get back to the ami
there I'm just gonna click on the left
hand side here but yeah that's all we
need to know for ami and we will move on
to auto scaling groups
all right so now that we've created an
ami we are ready to make an auto scaling
group so down below I want you to go to
auto scaling groups and so what an auto
scaling group does is it allows you to
ensure that multiple instances where
servers are running so if you always
wanted to guarantee that one server is
running an auto scaling group would have
a rule that would check to say is at
least one running and if not then launch
a new server also auto scaling groups
are used to meet the demand of whatever
traffic you have so let's say you have a
web application or website and it's
getting a lot of traffic and it's gonna
need more servers well auto scaling
groups will determine based on certain
metrics that the the web application
needs more servers and will spin up more
servers and when the demand of traffic
becomes lower than its going to remove
servers to meet the demand okay so what
we'll go ahead and do here is create a
new auto scaling group and oh they just
change this on me so I'm a little bit
confused but we'll just getting started
I think that's just a bit of a thing
there and then we're gonna choose our
ami so this is very similar to launching
ec2 instance but we already have our own
ami so I'm gonna go to my M eyes I'm
just gonna select that fresh one there
and we're going to stick with T to my
Chrome I'll go next we're gonna have to
name it this launch configuration so
we'll just name this fresh LLC we're
going to use the my ec2 role there we're
going to go ahead and add storage the
defaults look great there the security
groups look right there and we are going
to create launch configuration and we
are going to drop that down and proceed
without a key pair because we don't need
one and we're going to create that
launch configuration so now that we've
created a launch configuration we can go
ahead and create the auto scaling group
so we're gonna call this one
fresh ASG it sees for auto scaling group
we're gonna set the group size to one so
the number of instances the group should
have at any time so at minimum how many
servers should be running then we have
to have a network or a V PC and we need
to choose some subnets so we're gonna
choose one and then we're going to
choose a another one here okay we just
need a couple there I'm just going to
advanced details this all looks great
we're gonna configure our scaling
policies scheduling policies our ways
rules that you can use to determine how
the autoscanning groups should react to
changes within its environment right so
if you have a lot of CPU utilization
maybe that's when it spins up servers
maybe it's only when there's a lot of
data transfer in or when there's a lot
of memory so that's what scaling
policies allow you to do then we'll go
to notifications and then we'll go to
tags and then we will review and we'll
go ahead and create that auto scaling
group okay so it says that auto scaling
group has been created we'll hit close
and here we can see our fresh fresh ASG
it's using our launch configuration
which is our fresh LC currently there
are zero instances running the desired
capacity is one the minimum servers that
should be running is 1 the maximum
servers that should be running is 1 ok
so if we just move this up here and go
to instances it should try to start
spinning up servers to meet the minimum
demand which is 1 so I'm gonna hit a
refresh here and I'm just kind of
expecting to see a server starting here
if we're not seeing one here just yet
what I want you to do is right click
here on instances and go here and I bet
you a server is starting up so I don't
see any servers running here as of yet
ok so I'm just gonna hit refresh here
because usually they would just start
spinning up here but yeah we'll just
give this here a little moment here
because maybe it's just taking some time
to get started
so yeah we just had to wait even just a
minute there and I just hit refresh and
already we can see that this is now 1
and under our instances it is launching
a new instance ID so or sorry an
instance that's just the ID of the
instance so if we go back to our
instance tab and we just do a refresh
here we can see another instance is
spinning up ok so what we're gonna do is
we're going to just wait for that
instance to start and once once it does
we'll move on to the next step alright
so after waiting a few minutes here our
instance is now started here I'm just
going to select this one off here but
this is the instance here that is
running that's part of our auto scaling
group so
we said that auto-scaling groups they
can ensure that there's always at least
a minimum of servers running and so if
we were to terminate this instance so
I'm just going to go ahead and terminate
it what's going to happen is once it
shuts down we're gonna go back to our
auto scan of the group it's going to
detect that this one is no longer
healthy okay so see over here that it
says healthy right now but it will after
a while determine that it is unhealthy
and then what it will do as a response
it's going to launch a new instance so
we're just going to wait here for a
little bit until this is now flagged
unhealthy okay all right and so we can
now see that this instance is unhealthy
and so the way this auto scanning group
is going to respond is by launching a
new instance so now we're just gonna
wait here a little bit and just keep on
hanging this refresh button until we see
another instance spinning up to replace
this unhealthy one okay so I just hit
the refresh here and so that unhealthy
instance is gone and so I guess what
we're just going to wait for here is now
a healthy instance to replace that
unhealthy one so just to get back to
that that minimum of one server running
okay so we'll just go ahead here and
just refresh and so there we go so we
can see that we have a new server that
is starting up so we'll just wait until
that one is totally set up here and
we've now accomplished what we wanted
with autoscaler groups and we will just
destroy this auto scaling group all
right so our replacement instance is now
a healthy and in service so what I want
to do is go ahead and remove this auto
scaling group now I believe that when we
delete this auto scaling group it's
going to take down the instance as well
so we're not going to have to delete
that so I'm just gonna go ahead here and
delete the auto scaling group and we're
gonna say yes okay and so we are going
to just watch that delete there and hit
refresh there and also since we have
that instance tab open we'll hit refresh
here and so we have that instance
running so what we're hoping to see is
that this instance is torn down when we
have deleted this a lot of screen groups
so we'll just wait here a little bit and
see what happens
all right and so if we were to do a few
refresh is there it
deed is shutting down that instance that
was spun up by the auto scaling group so
when you delete your auto scaling group
it's going to take down those instances
as well so you know that's an it for the
auto scaling group section and we can
move on to elastic load balancer hey
this is Andrew Brown from exam pro and
we were going to learn about elastic
load bouncers also known as lbs and what
they do is they allow you to put a load
balancer in front of your instances and
the idea is that when traffic comes into
your web application it's gonna float
flow through the a load balancer and
it's going to evenly distribute that
traffic to multiple instances and your
instances generally will be running in
different availability zones so if one
AC becomes unavailable then your traffic
will then go to the other AZ where you
have it instance running so you do not
experience a downtime and your web
application remains running okay so now
that we have an idea what elby's are
let's go ahead and launch a few
instances so that we have something to
load balance to and so I'm gonna choose
Amazon olynyk's to here we are going to
stick with the teaching micro because it
is free I want you to select a two
instances here okay
and we're gonna leave all the settings
alone maybe we'll give I am role we do
not need to ssh into or sorry use SSM to
get into that instance but it doesn't
hurt to attach it there we're gonna
leave storage alone we're gonna go past
tags we're gonna go to our security
groups i'm going to set it to an
existing one and use the default one
every time you create a instance it
seems like it really encourages you to
keep making new security groups we don't
need to have a bunch of these so we'll
just go and use the existing one and i'm
going to review and then launch i'm
gonna drop down here and proceed without
a key pair because we don't need to keep
here
and so now these instances are going to
start up here and i'm just going to wait
until they get into a running state with
two status checks and we'll go ahead and
create art lbph alright so our two
instances are ready here and i just want
to go ahead and give them a name so i'm
gonna just call this one instance a
and then we will call this one instance
B okay
and now that I have those two instances
let's go make our way over to load
balancing here it's under the ec2
console and so we will click here and
what we will do is we will create
ourselves a new load balancer now there
are three types of load balancers we
have application load bouncer network
load bouncer and classical L balancer we
are going to be using application load
balancer here and that's generally what
you're going to be wanting to use we are
going to type in a lb or maybe my a lb
here it will be internet-facing okay we
need to ensure that it's running in at
least two availability zones or it's
going to complain to us so we'll go
ahead and do that we will go to the next
step here we aren't using SSL or HTTPS
so we don't have to do anything here for
security groups we will use the existing
security group the default one so that's
totally fine and for configuring routing
we're gonna have to create a new target
group a target group contains a
reference to the instances which we want
to wrote to so we are just going to make
a new one I had to say my target group
here and we can route things to a
different thing so it could be instances
or a specific IPS or lambdas so we're
going to stick with instances and we're
going to go ahead here and register
those targets so here we can see we have
instances here I'm just going to select
them and add to register so now they are
registered up here we're gonna hit next
and then we are going to go ahead and
create okay and so it takes very little
time for a load bouncer to create we
will then hit close here and this load
bouncer is now just provisioning so
we're just gonna wait here a little
while until this is provisioned and you
just have to hit the refresh here and
see when this is ready all right so our
load balancers ready it didn't really
take that long it took about a minute or
so and so just to poke around here you
can see that this load bouncer here has
a DNS name okay so this DNS name just
looks like a domain
and the way you would route your traffic
to the lots of little bouncers you'd
actually point it to here okay and so
all the traffic would go here and then
it would then go on to the listeners and
the listeners listen on a particular
port so this is port 80 and then it's
going to then have rules which is going
to forward this traffic to that target
group if we click into this target group
here all right what it's going to do is
going to show us the actual target so if
we go over here and look at targets it's
going to then rub it to the registered
targets so that's how an elastic load
balancer works and that's all we really
need to know for this but just to show
you how to make an elastic load balancer
so now that we're done here let's go
tear this stuff down so we'll go ahead
here and we will just go delete this
load bouncer now unlike the auto scaling
group which would actually tear down the
instances we have to take these
instances down ourselves and so what I
want you to do is select a and B here
and we were just going to terminate
these here okay and that is our elastic
load balancer section all right so we're
gonna learn a little bit about s3 here
so what I want you to do is go up to
services here and type in s3 and we will
go and make our way over to the s3
console here and so the first thing I
want you to notice that when you come to
s3 that it is global here so s3 does not
require our region selection however the
buckets that we're going to create will
be region specific and the idea here is
a bucket is just a place to contain your
files okay so we will just create a
bucket here and we're gonna give it a
name so I'm gonna call this exam pro
fresh now these names are globally
unique it's just like selecting a domain
name so if the name you have here
selected is not available you'll just
have to change the name and we have the
option to to choose the region so I'm
gonna go ahead here and create this
bucket so now I have a bucket and we can
start uploading files to this bucket so
I'll go ahead here and just hit upload
and what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
add some files and so from my desktop I
have a photo of me I'm gonna hit open
here I'm going to up
load that there and so now we have a a
file here in s3 okay and so if I want to
download it I can just hit that download
button there and that will allow us to
download that file and there's a variety
of different things that you can do in
s3 but that is just the most basic
things you need to know about s3 okay
but we aren't going to delete this
bucket because we're going to use it in
combination with our next thing which is
using cloud front okay so I'm just gonna
make my way back here to the home page
here and we'll move on to the next part
alright so we're going to take a look at
the cloud front so cloud front is used
as a CDN a content distribution network
and the idea here is let's say you have
files static files or video files that
you want to share across the world but
you want those to load as quickly as
possible and make the shortest route to
the end user and that is where a cloud
front which is a clock content
distribution network comes in so it's
going to take whatever your static
content is and it's going to then copy
it to multiple edge locations around the
world and so when someone tries to
access your content it's going to go to
that nearby edge location as opposed to
going really far away to get that
content so let's make our way over to
cloud front here so just drop-down
services and type in cloud front ok and
we will make our way over here and we're
going to need to create ourselves the
distribution however we'll just get
started here and I want you to drop this
down and just choose that as three
bucket that we created okay and pretty
much all the settings here are totally
fine so we're just going to go down
below here and create that distribution
okay and creating distributions take
quite some time to to happen but the
idea there is remember how I upload that
one file to my bucket there so what this
distribution is going to do it's going
to copy that file and then move it to
all those servers around the world so
that now my content is a super fast okay
and just like elastic load bouncer where
it had a
DNS name where you could hit it like a
domain name to access it says Claude
front is similar so here we have a
domain name here so your traffic would
hit this domain name and then it would
then route your traffic to the nearest
edge location okay so that's all there
really is to it here distributions take
a really long time to create so we don't
really need to wait for this to a
complete so I'm gonna just disable this
here okay and it's going to just disable
and once it's disabled you can delete it
even if you don't delete it it's not
gonna cost you anything here because it
will be disabled but yeah once it's done
disabling you can go ahead and select it
and then delete it all right so that's
fall front alright so now we're going to
look at RDS which stands for relational
database service and it is for setting
up relational databases so I want you to
make your way over to the RDS console so
go to the top here and type RDS and
we'll click that and once in we're here
in the console we're going to create
ourselves a new database so on the
left-hand side here go to databases and
then create a database and we're gonna
be presented with quite a few options
here okay
and so by default it has the Amazon or
rora engine selected this is one of the
most expensive options so we definitely
do not want to use that so we will just
use Postgres for our case here and the
next thing is we have some templates to
get us started here and so we have
production dev tests and free tier and
these are all suited for different needs
so the idea with production is if you
are a larger a very very large company
they're setting you up with every Bell
and whistle Under the Sun here where dev
test is for small to medium sized
companies and free tier is definitely
just for a gain hands-on experience
which is what we're doing here or just
for testing simple application so I just
want to show you the price difference
here so they have a calculation down
below so if I scroll all the way down
below here you can see that for
production it's $600 a month which is
quite a bit of money and then if we have
a dev test and we scroll down here now
it's 262 dollars still
quite expensive and then we go the free
tier and now there is no cost showing
because it is free okay but you only get
750 hours on RDS and so for a t2 micro
and then once that is used up then if
you use the t2 micro for a month it will
cost you around $15 per month and again
if you are a very small startup you can
run on the free tier and the lowest here
for quite a while but you know for some
reason ADA busts decides to always have
the most expensive one selected here
with RDS so we just have to be careful
there so let's go to free tier because
it is the use case for us we have the DB
instance identifier we'll leave that
alone that's totally fine we need to set
a password so I'm just gonna type in
Postgres one two three okay and then
Postgres one two three
then you have your DB instance size we
of course want to leave it on t2 micro
here because we want to have the
smallest instance there's nothing
smaller there's no nano here on RDS like
ec2 then we choose our storage it's set
to 20 gigabytes there is auto scaling
for storage so it will automatically
increase the size if that runs out I
don't turn that off because we don't
need that you have your multi a Z you
can determine where this RDS should
launch like what V PC we're gonna leave
in the default for database
authentication we can use the standard
password authentication or if you want
to allow I am users to authenticate
directly you can use that which is
pretty cool I'm just gonna leave it to
password authentication and then we have
additional configuration which you
definitely want to set so you have your
initial database name so if you do not
specify database name RDS does not
create a database so I'm pretty sure we
want to create a database here so we're
gonna have to name this here so I'm
going to call this exam pro fresh ok and
we're gonna turn backups off ok and oh I
guess apparently I can't use the hyphen
there so I'll just remove that actually
it looks like I can use them underscore
and so but anyway so if we turn this off
to 0 days that means it's not going to
take a snapshot right away or a backup
right away it's gonna launch a lot
faster and we're not doing much with a
server so you know let's just get
through this as quickly
as possible we don't need a performance
insight so I'm going to turn that off as
well and yeah we were all good to go so
we'll go ahead and create that database
okay and so we're just going to wait for
the creation of that database there and
it will just take a little bit of time
here and we'll be back in a moment all
right so now our database is available
here and you can just see when clicking
into it that we get stuff such as the
CPU usage currently and how many current
connections are connected to this
database here now in order to actually
access this database you'd have to
assemble all the requirements so you'd
have to use this endpoint you'd need
this port number
we need the database name the user name
password which we had set earlier and
then you could use a traditional tool
maybe a table plus or something to make
a connection and start using that
database okay but you know for our
purposes it was just a matter of showing
how easy it is to create a database here
and so now that we have created our own
database let's go ahead and just destroy
that database okay and so I'm gonna go
ahead here I just have to type in delete
me okay and that's already yes for you
so this will just delete here just gonna
hit refresh and we're totally good here
I'm just going to go back to the magic
so we're gonna take a look at Ava's
lambda here and see how to run a lambda
function so what I want you to do is go
to the top here to services and just
type in a lambda and we'll make our way
over to the lambda console and once
we're in here I want you to go ahead and
create a new function and we are going
to author one from scratch so I'm just
gonna say am i a lambda okay and we have
a bunch of different runtimes that we
can choose here we have no GS etc I'm
gonna choose Ruby cuz that's my language
of choice we're gonna drop down here and
we are going to have it create us a new
role with basic lambda permissions so
that it can write to cloud watch logs
and we're gonna hit go ahead and create
that function
okay great so that function has now been
set up here for us and if we just scroll
down here you can see that we have this
nice little inline editor that allows us
to work on our function okay and so the
big benefit alanda it's you don't have
to worry about the the server's you just
write your code and it will run the
trade-off here is though that these only
run for a small amount of time so lambda
can only run for up to 15 minutes but
generally they are they only run for one
second or less that's generally how
they're used let's go ahead here and
let's just put a puts in here so I can
just say hello world just so we can see
that our lambda works and what we can do
here is we can go up and make a test so
I'm just gonna go ahead here and make a
test and we already have one here called
hello world and I'm just gonna type this
in again hello world here oh maybe I
have to do this and I'm just gonna hit
create there and so now I have a test
and I'm just going to go ahead and hit
test there and we can see that it's
succeeded and we get a status code so
this is what it would return and if we
were to go check the logging here if we
were to go to monitoring here all right
we should be able to see that that puts
that we have there okay so we just click
on this button here view logs in cloud
watch and we can see that lambda ran
there and you know I don't have any
output here as I forgot to hit save
they're really finicky about that and
now if I hit test okay it's worked and
now the output here actually has hello
world okay so that's from the logs well
if I go back here and give this a hard
refresh here okay I might have to go
back one step here because now it's in
this one up here and we should have our
our puts the right one maybe it just oh
there it is okay so I'll just in patient
here but it's showed up so there you go
so you can see lambdas are pretty darn
simple and just going back here up to
the function lambdas get triggered from
a variety of different services so if
you want to add a trigger you can go
here and
drop down and choose a service so you
could have it so anytime something is
inserted into DynamoDB it would then
trigger that lambda function or from a
variety of things okay and there's even
integration with third-party third-party
Amazon partners okay so yeah that's all
we need to know for lambda so we're
gonna take a look at the ec2 pricing
model and there are four ways we can pay
with ec2 we have on demand spot reserved
and dedicated and we're going to go
through each section and see where each
one makes sense
so we're gonna take first a look at on
demand pricing and this is whenever you
launch an ec2 instance it's gonna by
default use on demand and so on demand
has no upfront payment and no long-term
commitment you're only charged by the
hour or by the minutes gonna vary based
on the ec2 instance type and that's how
the pricing is gonna work and you might
think okay what's the use case here well
on demand is for applications where the
workload is short-term spike you're
unpredictable when you have a new app
for development or you want to just run
an experiment this is where on demand is
going to be a good fit for you
so we're taking a look at reserved
instances also known as RI and these are
going to give you the best long-term
savings and it's designed for
applications that have steady-state
predictable usage or require reserved
capacity so what you're doing is you're
saying to AWS you know I'm gonna make a
commitment to you and I'm gonna be using
this over the next period of time and
they're gonna give you savings okay so
this reduced pricing is gonna be based
on three variables we have term class
offerings and payment options and we'll
walk through these things to see how
they all work so for payment options we
have standard convertible and scheduled
standards gonna give us the greatest
savings with seventy five percent
reduced pricing and this is compared to
obviously two on demand the thing here
though is that you cannot change the RI
attributes the tributes being like
instance type right so whatever you have
you're you're stuck with it now if you
need a bit more flexibility because you
might need to have more room to grow in
the future
you'd look at convertible so the savings
aren't gonna be as great we're looking
at up to 54% but now you have the
ability to let's say change your
instance type to a larger size you can't
go smaller but you can always go larger
and you but you're gonna have some
flexibility there then there's scheduled
and this is one you need to reserved
instances for a specific time period
this could be the case where you always
have a workload that's predictable every
single Friday for a couple hours and the
idea is by telling you WS that you're
gonna be doing out on schedule then
we'll give you savings there that's
gonna vary the other two things is term
and payment options the terms is how
long are you willing to commit one year
or through your contract the greater the
term is the greater the savings and you
have payment options so you have all up
front
partial up front and no up front no
fronts the most interesting one because
you could say you know I'm gonna use a
server for a year and you and you'll
just pay at the end of the month and so
that is a really good way of saving
money right off the bat a lot of people
don't seem to know that so you know mix
those three together and that's gonna
change the the outcome there and I do
here have a graphic to show you that you
can select things and to show you how
they would estimate the actual cost for
you a couple things you wanted about
reserved
that can be shared between multiple
accounts within a single organization
and unreserved our eyes can be sold in
the reserved instance marketplace so if
you do buy into a one or through your
contract you're not fully out of luck
because you can always try to resell it
to somebody else who might want to use
it so there you go so now we're taking a
look at spa instances and they have the
opportunity to give you the biggest
savings with ninety percent discount
compared to on-demand pricing there are
some caveats though so eight of us has
all this unused compute capacity so they
want to maximize utility of their idle
servers it's no different than when a
hotel offers discounts to fill vacant
suites or when the plane offers
discounts to fill vacant seats ok so
there's just ec2 instances lying around
it would be better to give people
discounts then for them to do nothing so
the only Cabot though is that when you
use spot instances if another customer
who wants to pay on demand a higher
price wants to use it and they need to
give that capacity to that on-demand
user this instance can be terminated at
any given time okay and that's going to
be the trade off so just looking at
termination termination conditions down
below and since this can be terminated
by Avis at any time if your instance is
terminated by a SS you don't get charged
for the partial hour of usage but if you
were to terminate an instance you will
still be charged for any hour that it
ran okay so there you go that's the
little Kabat to it um but what would you
use spot instances for if it can if
these instances could be interrupted
anytime well they're designed for
applications that have flexible start
and end times or applications that are
only feasible at very low compute costs
and so you can see I pulled out the
configuration graphic when you make
spots so it's saying like is it for load
balancing workloads flexible workloads
big data workloads are defined duration
workloads so you can see there is some
definitions as to what kind of utility
would have there but there you are
so we're taking a look at dedicated host
instances which is our most expensive
option with ec2 pricing models and it's
designed to meet regulatory requirements
when you have strict server bound
licensing that won't support
multi-tenancy or cloud deployments so to
really understand dedicated hosts we
need to understand multi-tenant versus
single tenant so whatever you launch an
ec2 instance and zhuzhing on demand or
any of the other types beside dedicated
host its multi tenant meaning you are
sharing the same hardware as other ATS
customers and the only separation
between you and other customers is
through virtualized isolation which is
software okay then you have single
tenant and this is what a single
customer has dedicated hardware and so
customers are separated through physical
isolation all right and so to just
compare these two I think of multi
tenant as like everyone living in an
apartment and single 10 is everyone
living in a house right so you know why
would we want to have our own dedicated
Hardware well large enterprises and
organizations may have security concerns
or obligations about sharing the same
hardware with other eight of us
customers so it really just boils down
to that with dedicated hosts it comes in
an on-demand flavor and a reserved
flavor okay so you can save up to 70%
but overall dedicated hosts is way more
expensive than our other ecq pricing
options so we're on to the ec2 pricing
cheat sheet and this one is a two pager
but we'll make our way through it
so ec2 has four pricing models we have
on-demand spot reserved instances also
known as RI and dedicated looking first
at on-demand
it requires the least commitment from
you it is low cost and flexible you only
pay per hour and the use cases here are
for short term spiky unpredictable
workloads or first time applications
it's gonna be ideal when you want
workloads that cannot be interrupted
whereas in spot that's when you can have
interruption and we'll get to that here
shortly so on to reserved instances you
can save up to
75% off its gonna give you the best
long-term value the use case here are
steady-state or predictable usage you
can resell unused reserved instances in
the reserved instance marketplace the
reduced pricing is gonna be based off of
these three variables terms class
offering and payment option so for
payment terms we have a one-year or a
three-year contract with payment options
we can either pay all upfront partial
upfront or no upfront and we have three
class offerings we have standards
convertible and scheduled so for
standard we're gonna get up to
seventy-five percent reduced pricing
compared to on-demand but you cannot
change those Aria attributes meaning
like if you want to change to a larger
instance type it's not gonna be possible
you're stuck with what you have if you
want a bit more flexibility we have
convertible where you can get up to
fifty four percent off and you get that
flexibility as long as those are a
attributes' are greater than or equal in
value you can change those values then
you have scheduled and this is used this
is for reserved instances for specific
time periods so maybe you want to run
something once a week for a few hours
and the savings here are gonna vary now
on to our last two pricing models we
have spot pricing which is up to 90
percent off it's gonna give you the
biggest savings what you're doing here
is you're requesting spare computing
capacity so you know as we said earlier
it's like hotel rooms where they're just
trying to fill the vacant Suites if you
are if you're comfortable with flexible
start and end times spot price is gonna
be good for you the use case here is if
you can handle an eruption so servers
randomly stopping and starting it's a
very good use case is for non-critical
background jobs instances can be
terminated by a BS at any time if your
instance is terminated by eight of us
you won't get charged for that partial
hour of usage if you terminate that
instance you will be charged for any
hour that it ran in okay and the last is
dedicated hosting it's the most
expensive option and it's just dedicated
servers okay and so it can be it can be
utilized an on-demand or reserved so you
can save up to 70% off and the use case
here is when you need a guarantee of
isolate hardware so this is like
enterprise requirements so there you go
we made it all the way through ec2
alright so there are many ADA best
services that do not incur a cost and so
these are three services so for example
I am which is used for creating users
and groups and roles to access different
resources creating any of those
components of I am are not going to
incur a cost so I am is essentially a
free service where you have these other
services which are free such as
auto-scaling CloudFormation elastic
beanstalk everything in this blue box
but they can provision other aid of a
services which costs money so on the
exam I would not be surprised if you
come across a question which kind of
implies that CloudFormation might incur
a cost but you just need to know that
the service itself is free but it can
provision other services okay so I've
highlighted in bold here the services
which I think would most likely show up
on the exam but I've given you more of a
full list of things that definitely do
not cost money so there you go so eight
of us has four different support plans
to help you up when you need it and when
you first make an AWS account you by
default are in the basic support plan
and this is gonna give you access via
email for billing and account
information so let's say you aren't sure
about the cost of something or you think
that you might have been over billed or
you are you're suspecting that you may
be over billed because you might have
missed configured something you have
this available to you at all tiers but
yeah that's the first thing that you
have access to and so you just send them
an email and they'll help you resolve
that now coming into the paid tiers
we're gonna start with developer
starting at $20 USD and this is gonna
give you access to technical support via
email okay and generally they will reply
within 24 hours but they do allow you to
choose the response time like the nature
of the issue which is going to determine
how fast they reply and so we have
general guidance and system impaired
okay now in the developer tier it does
not provide third-party support so let's
say you had a web application whether
it's Ruby on
or Django or Express to us and is
running on an ec2 instance ATI bus is
going to help you with the ec2 instance
but they're not going to help you with
the actual third party part which would
be you know again rails or Django and
etc okay so so you know that's what's
going to be limited to going into the
next tier business which starts at 100
USD this is now where you're going to
have access to chat and phone and this
is any times okay so if you want to call
them at 3m in the morning you can or
chat with them and generally it might be
a bit slower to connect with them but
they definitely will connect with you
and you can work through your problems
okay so the other advantage here is that
now that you can do chat and phone you
can also do screen sharing with them so
they can actually send you over link and
now they can see your screen and they
can work through the problem with you
and this is extremely useful and
definitely makes the business here
something worth purchasing especially if
you're running a production system okay
you're also going to get faster response
times in the case of if you have a
production system impaired or down okay
so this might be important to you and so
also the business tier and enterprise
here does support third-party ok so on
these tiers they will make the best
effort to try to help you through things
that aren't eighth abyss related to
solve your problem ok so that is an
additional bonus there now coming into
the enterprise account this is the most
expensive plan starting at 15,000 USD it
was previously 10,000 but eight of us
has increased that and this plan is
special because you actually get two
dedicated resources these and YNS a
resources I mean people and so you get a
personal concierge and a tam which
stands for a Technical Account Manager
and also you have a new response time
where they can respond within 15 minutes
in the case for a business critical
system down ok so there's that and then
we have advisor checks okay so for
adviser checks for the basic developer
we have
and then for business and a prize we get
all checks do we have another section in
this course here where we cover trusted
advisors so you can see what all those
checks are but for the exam you're gonna
need to know the difference
pricing for the different tiers you're
going to need to know those response
times the 2412 for one hour 15 minutes
you need to know when our people
assigned your accountants only in the
enterprise you're gonna need to know
when third-party support is is there or
not yeah so there you go
so here in this follow along I want to
show you how you would go ahead and
create a case in aid of its support I am
using the business support plan here and
you can see that I have a bunch of
different support cases I definitely
have a lot on a cloud front because it's
given us a lot of trouble but anyway
let's work our way through this and
create a new case here and then you're
gonna be presented with a type of case
you want to choose so if you were on the
basic tier technical support would be
grayed out you'd have access to both
account a billing support and service
limit increase so if I just click here
you can see here if I want to report a
billing thing I can choose to the type
so I'd say billing I would choose the
category so I could say I have a
question about the free tier and then
you could specify the response time here
okay Lord I guess they called the
severity and you'd write your subject
description you can attach up to three
attachments there and you can only
choose to talk to them via email
okay so we have chat and phone but these
are disabled but I think the real
interesting thing to show you in support
here is technical support okay so with
technical support this is where we're
going to be able to ask technical
questions about each of the services so
if I wanted to drop something down and
we would type in a cloud front here
because again I said claw front is
something we spent a lot of time on and
then you choose the category and so now
the category is going to narrow down
based on the service and on the right
hand side they are going
give you suggestions okay but we can go
through here and say I'm having an issue
with caching okay and then you could
choose the severity so we'll just leave
it general and then sometimes they ask
you to provide additional information
it's optional but it's going to save
them time to help you out you'd have to
go through your account to find of those
values it's going to change based on the
service and then down below we can write
in whatever we want so I could say I'm
having issues with my distribution okay
my cash values aren't showing up aren't
being served okay
and so you could choose the preferred
contact here now this is very simple you
don't get any type of formatting or
bolding so you have to be a bit creative
to display that information but you
definitely want to try to create all the
steps for them to replicate it okay and
then down below we have web chat or
phone so we'll give chat a try here okay
and I'm just gonna hit submit and then
we will get here is um a chat window
pop-up there okay and so we'll just wait
here for a little bit well I just wanted
to give you actually a better example
here so I just left that window there
and opened up a previous case I had here
this one actually is with CloudFront
lamda edge and so once you are chatting
with the cloud engineer it will actually
save all this within the case later on
so if you need to read what you were
talking about that's going to be saved
there later if for whatever reason the
cloud engineer cannot solve it and they
need to go off and try to replicate it
or reach out to someone else on the team
they will do so and then they will come
back to you with the answer later and so
they will provide that there and that's
what happened in the case here okay and
generally sometimes they will go out and
actually bring back even more
information for you there okay so you
can even see that this cloud engineer
had to go talk to the cloud formation
team to resolve this case here so you
definitely can really reach the experts
within eight of
to solve your problems so there you go
that's generally the fall along here in
a nutshell from created case ok so now
we're taking a look at AWS marketplace
which is a curated digital catalog with
thousands of software listings from
independent software vendors it allows
you to easily find buying test and
deploy software that already runs on AWS
so on the right hand side there you can
see we have a bunch of categories such
as operating system security machine
learning and the idea is that you would
click into one of those categories and
now you have a bunch of aprox that are
being offered to you in the form of
Amazon machine images CloudFormation
templates SAS offerings laugh rules and
a variety of more and these products can
either be free or they could have an
associative charge more likely the
latter and this charge will become part
of your AWS bill and if you want to sell
things yourself there is a sales channel
4 is fees and consulting partners so you
definitely cannot just be the one buying
but also selling okay so in this fall
log I want to show you the Animus
marketplace and the things that you
could possibly buy in here so just
looking here on the home page here we
have a bunch of categories where we can
narrow down the thing that we're looking
for or we could choose a vendor if we
knew in particular what we want you can
see there's a thousand three hundred
sixty-one vendors so there's quite a few
here or if you want to determine your
pricing plans or delivery methods okay
and then you have those popular
categories which is a very easy way to
start exploring maybe we would be
interested in machine learning so I'll
go ahead and click there ok
and now that we are a machine learning
we can see that we have a variety of
different offerings here so let's say we
wanted to do some deep learning with
Python 3 and tensorflow I'm just gonna
click into here it's gonna give you an
idea what kind of product we have here I
believe this is an Amazon machine image
I'm just kind of trying to find where it
says that and write down there so we see
that the delivery methods is an Amazon
machine image so it's going to determine
what that is and we have a variety of
information here such as the product
overview it'll do price estimating
estimations based on the ec2 instance
that you choose and there could be
useful information such as how to
actually use this okay so yeah so if you
wanted to do that I mean you could
create a subscription from here but
generally when you're launching Amazon
machine images you'd want to go ahead
and launch that within the ec2 console
there so let's hop our way over there
and try to find something in the
marketplace okay all right so here I am
in my AWS account and I'm gonna make my
way over to ec2 okay so a lot of times
when you want to use a marketplace
resource generally you're going to
launch it within the context of what
service you're using so there are laughs
rules that are sold within the
marketplace so when you're using laughs
in the laughs console you can purchase
them there and when it's going to be an
ami it's going to be via ec2 okay so I
would just go ahead here and launch an
instance and as soon as I launch an
instance here or get to the option to
choose to launch an instance whenever it
decides to load we are going to be
presented with the ami that we need to
choose okay all right so now we can
choose our am I on the left hand side
you're gonna see AWS marketplace and so
this is where it's gonna make it easy
for us to choose a service there and
subscribe to it so if we wanted that
machine learning one I think it was
tensorflow okay so we type tensorflow
there I'm not quite exactly the same one
but if we just wanted to launch one here
so here we have deep learning ami which
is Ana Bunton and it would have some
kind of Associated cost here so I go
here and select it okay and right away
it's going to show me the pricing here I
don't see any additional cost probably
because this one is an eighth of us deep
learning AMI it probably doesn't have
any additional cost but it does estimate
that stuff out there so maybe we'll go
I can actually to something where I know
there will definitely be a cost maybe we
try launching guacamole
okay so guacamole is a if you can spell
it is a is a bastion I'll just type in
Bastion that's an easier way to find it
so here's guacamole it gives you a free
trial and here you can see the pricing
here so you see 0.3 cents to 33 point 52
cents per hour and so I will just go
ahead and select that okay and choose
that ami and you can tell you that it
has a free instance and then you'd hit
continue okay and then you just launch
your instance so based on this here I'm
restricted to that so I'll just do a
small here and I'm just gonna go ahead
and review and launch okay and this is
definitely not part of the free tier so
I'm gonna definitely want to destroy
this immediately after creating it okay
but I just want to show you how easy it
is to create something from the ec2
marketplace here okay I'll just download
that and launch that alright and so now
I actually have a subscription to that
market pay up place a service okay
so as that is launching there usually
doesn't take this long but today it
seems to be a bit slower I want to show
you the actual u.s. marketplace
subscription so when you start
accumulating subscriptions you can go to
a to this marketplace subscriptions here
and see that apparently it's not
supported in the Canada region so we'll
have to move over to US East that's not
uncommon for AWS because a lot of times
with billing and other things they are
only available in the u.s. East region
but here you can see we have guacamole
okay and it's saying our trial ends in
five days and then I have over here a
lamp certified by bit not me and it has
no additional cost
so if you are using a bunch of things
from the marketplace and you're trying
to keep track of them this is where
you're going to find that information
okay so I mean that's pretty much all
you need to know for the ablest
marketplace and I'm just going to make
sure to shut down that instance there
since I do actually not want to do
anything with it okay I just wanted to
show you how easy it was to start
subscribing to a resource there so I'm
just gonna go here and quickly
shut down that instance there so if
you're following along you do the same
so I'll just go ahead here and terminate
that instance okay hey this is Angie
Brown from exam Pro and we are looking
at trusted advisor which advises you on
security saving money performance
service limits and fault tolerance the
reason I have that saving money and
right is because we are looking at
billing and pricing okay and for trusted
advisor for every single account you're
gonna get for free seven trust advisor
checks if you have either business or
enterprise support you're gonna get all
trusted advisor checks and an easy way
of thinking what trusted advisor is is
think of it as an automated checklist
for best practices on AWS so trusted
advisor has five different categories
where it can advise you on and it has
checks and these are all the checks that
are possible that are at the paid tiers
okay for the free tier there's quite a
few less I can honestly can't remember
what they are so I'm not gonna show them
here to you
and we're just going to focus on the
full list here going through each
category so first looking at cost
optimization where you're gonna be able
to save money the two most common ones
where it will recommend you on is idle
load bouncers and on associate EW so for
idle load balancers the so if you spin
up an elastic load bouncer the minimum
cost per month is $15 okay but let's say
you just don't happen to have any ec2
instances that are being balanced on
there it's gonna say hey this load
balancers not doing anything maybe you
should get rid of it to save some money
another one is a IPS so that's a lot of
sick IP addresses okay and so the idea
is that if you have an ec2 instance and
you want to give it a static IP you can
reserve any IP from AWS but the thing is
is that if it's not attached to an ec2
instance its unassociated it costs you
money because AWS want you to release
that that IP address so someone else can
use it so that's a recommendation it
will make to you looking at performance
let's say we look at high utilization
Amazon ec2 instances so for that one I
believe that it's let's say you have a
very high CPU use
on an ec2 instance it's gonna say hey
maybe you should use a larger instance
okay to get better performance out of
this this machine here okay now for
security we have MFA enroute account and
this is not only trust advisor tells you
to do this but so many other ADA bus
services tell you to do it because it's
such a important security measure within
your eight of us account another thing
could be I am access key rotation so you
have access keys that are used by users
and it might suggest hey it's time to
rotate these up to make sure things stay
secure okay so looking at the last of
categories we have fault tolerance and
service limits so for fault tolerance it
would recommend let's say something for
RDS backups okay so just to make sure
that you have backups in place or have
them turned on so in the case that your
database goes down you can recover it
okay and then you have service limits
and there's none in particular chosen
here but there are limitations on the
certain amount of things that you can
use and ableist allows you to increase
those limits so it's just kind of like a
safeguard for us if you're allowed to go
beyond that I guess a really good one
would be SCS so SCS allows you to send
out emails and probably by default it
caps you at like five thousand or ten
thousand emails and if you had to go
beyond that you would ask for a service
limit increase okay so those are all the
checks there and the five categories to
give you an idea what trust advisor can
help you with
so in this follow along I want to show
you trusted advisor dashboard and how it
makes recommendations to you and how you
can keep up to date when it discovers
new things ok so here in this example
account we have business applied so we
have all the eight of us advisor checks
so let's go take a look at cost
optimization here and you can see that
we have things in green so these things
are a-okay and then you have things with
warnings and one thing we explored
earlier was an associate an associated
elastic IP addresses if we expand there
it's going to show us that we have one
IP address in our US East region that's
not currently associated with any
running instance so this thing is
costing us money okay so so then you'd
have to go take action and go over to
ability that's in V PC the V PC console
and then just unassociated you'd start
saving money okay and so we have that
for a bunch of categories here if you
wanted to download a report I believe
you could go up here and download an XLS
yep that's the next Celeste there so you
can bring that into Excel and look at
that information but the number one
thing I want to show you is preferences
and under preferences you can actually
set up email notifications on a weekly
basis so you would just set those email
addresses checkbox them save those
preferences and you would get these
notifications anytime there would be a
change where it has recommendations for
you you could take action on that so
that is all you really need to know for
trust advisors - there you go so we're
gonna take a look here at consolidating
billing which is a feature that is
turned on by default when you are using
Ava's organization's and you have
multiple member accounts so you're gonna
have one account that's considered your
master account within your organization
and then you'll have all these member
accounts underneath and all of their
billing information is going to be sent
to the master account as well as the
master account is going to be
responsible for paying the charges for
all its member accounts okay so it makes
billing very simple and straightforward
and also you'll be able to cost explore
to visualize the usage of the billing
per
if you wanted to see all the expenses
just for the developer account or the
data science science account or the
security account you're going to be able
to segment that data within class
explorer consolidate billing is offered
it a no additional cost okay and if you
do have a member account and you have it
leave the organization that cost
Explorer data is going to be no longer
available so just keep that in
consideration okay so another thing we
want to touch on about consolidating
billing is volume discounts so eight of
us has volume discounts for many
services so what that means is the more
you use something the more you are going
to save okay
and so consolidate some solid eight
billion lets you take advantage of
volume discounts because it's going to
take the usage for multiple accounts and
treat it as one and then whatever that
surplus of from another account is going
to end up in another bracket of of lower
discounts so just to really illustrate
this here we have usage from two
different accounts so we have Odo's
usage and datas you Dax's usage for data
transfer okay and so the data transfer
is going to cost at the first ten
terabytes seventeen cents per gigabyte
and the next 40 gigabytes is going to be
a 13 cents per gigabyte okay so if you
were just paying for Odo's usage and Dax
uses separately which would be
unconsolidated you could see that comes
out to two thousand eighty eight and
ninety-six cents okay but when you
consolidate the billing and a group the
total usage you're gonna have that usage
overflow into tier two which is where
you're gonna save that money okay and so
now you can see the consolidated billing
it's gonna be two thousand and seven
dollars and four cents so we have
roughly there about eighty dollars worth
of saving okay and so if we if those
costs weren't consolidated we wouldn't
get those savings so that's one
motivation for you to take your
individual accounts and make sure
they're in an organization okay
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at eight of us costs
Explorer which helps you visualize
understand and manage your AWS cost and
usage over time so with cost Explorer if
you have multiple Ageless accounts
within an organization all the costs
will be consolidated into the master
count so cost Explorer is very good at
giving getting an overview of all your
costs no matter what accounts they are
in within a bus' cost Explorer you have
these things called reports okay and a
dress gives you a bunch of reports by
default that you can use so if you need
to start breaking costs down based on
services or etc there just one click
away and you of course can make your own
reports within cost Explorer it has a
feature called forecasting which allows
you to see future costs so you can plan
for the future or maybe make adjustments
so you can lower your bill within cost
Explorer if you want to view the data
monthly or daily that is an option that
is available to you and you get these
nice graphs with in class Explorer so
you can group the information in a
variety of different ways you can see
there's tons of different ways and you
can also filter based on a lot of
options there so if you want to filter
out very specific services or very
specific regions or based on tags or
maybe you just want to look at one
particular like accounts and maybe you
have a developer account you just want
to see what they're spending then you
you can use those filters to narrow that
stuff to all right hey this is Angie
Brown from exam Pro and we are going to
do a quick follow along here in Ava's
cost Explorer here okay and so here I
have an example a Bo's account which has
some expenses within it so hopefully we
will find some useful information here
to look at as an example on how would
you use cost Explorer so here I am on
the home right so if I was to click here
this is what we would see and right away
we're gonna get month month to day cost
so
here so far we've spent $185 this month
and then it's forecasting $466 in 18
cents I do need to point out that these
forecast forecasts and monthly costs can
be misleading so if you have a large
spike or bill at the start of a month
because you might have large services so
like you paying freedom support or
you're registering domains like one-time
fixed costs this value here can be
extremely misleading so next month I'm
not paying $466 I definitely know that
but you know just be aware of that if
you see that and it might shock you okay
so just to start looking at information
we go to explore costs okay and right
away now we have our nice graph here and
it allows us to now filter this data
however we want so here we have that
group by and so the most convenient one
is generally by service okay and so what
you'll get is a stacked bar graph here
which will break down service costs now
it doesn't always show everything as you
can see here we have our business
support or RDS some other you see two
instances that are probably managed by
AWS maybe UCS or something then we have
Kinesis analytics and then we have
others okay so you don't get a full
picture there but they do have cost
listed down below you can download the
CSV and work with this raw data here
okay and you could break this down
monthly so I can go to monthly here okay
and then this will just change the graph
so now it's a monthly breakdown and you
can change the scope of how far you want
to go back there okay but we'll just go
back there and change it to daily and
apparently we have some other options
here so if you don't like stacked and
you like line graphs you can have that
or if you like bars okay but stack stack
is my preference there okay and then on
the right hand side we have filters so
if we want to start filtering it might
look like this is grayed out but what
you do is you actually click here okay
and so then I could type something like
registar okay if I can remember how to
spell it there we go and that's for
registering domains on run 53 and if I
just apply that filter there you can see
I have a one cost there okay and there's
tons of different filters in here okay
and tons but like the one that you'll
notice the most is like linked accounts
so if you wanted to filter out for like
a developer account like a discount or
saw like a variety of different counts
you can do that to figure out the exact
cost of particular teams okay
and so that's that there now just to
show you those reports there are those
default reports here if you go on the
left hand side here we can go to save
reports okay and so here are a bunch of
them there and you can get idea what's
inside of them okay but yeah you
basically would just create whatever
configuration you want
oops I went into reserved utilization
there I don't care about that but yeah
whatever whatever filters you want you
just go ahead and make any report and
you go cost and usage okay and from
there once you choose your configuration
you hit save and you can have this
report for later okay so if you really
want to monitor like cloud front so
cloud front is something that we heavily
use at exam Pro and it can fluctuate
based on how many people are consuming
videos on our platform we might want to
just create a report for cloud front
okay so yeah there you go
hey this is Angie Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at eight of us
budgets which is a services helped you
plan service usage service costs and
instance reservations I like to think of
it as building alarms on steroids and
when you use eight of us budgets each
budget costs about two cents per day
okay and you have up to a limit of
twenty thousand budgets but the first
two budgets are free of charge so if you
have a need of this account you
definitely want to go ahead and create
yourself a couple of budgets okay all
right so we're looking at Ava's budgets
here a little bit more detail and so the
idea here is that you can set up alerts
if you exceed or are approaching your
defined budget there are three types of
budgets you can create you have cost
usage and reservation okay so cost is
where you're just plugging in a dollar
amount there okay for usage it's going
to be based on a usage unit so you could
choose something such as ec2 running
hours and then you're going to supply
whatever the unit is so that's gonna be
hours in this case so here I've supplied
100 and you can track budgets
monthly quarterly or yearly levels okay
and so just if you said it for a year
then that alert is really going to be
designed to be delivered at the end of
the year okay so for reservations that
is for reserved instances and it was
budget supports ec2 redshift RDS and
elastic cash okay now when you are
defining your budget so you can define
them based on a fixed cost or you can
plan plan it upfront based on your
chosen levels so you could say for each
so for next six months you could say for
this month I want to spend this and for
this month I want to spend that etc etc
okay and if it was quarterly you could
say what you want those budgets to be
for those quarters okay you can also
easily manage ava's budgets via the
dashboard and they also have an API so
if you need to do something pragmatic
you can definitely do something there
and normally you'd get notified by email
but you could also have the notification
sent to chatbot okay so for a chatbot
that is a newer service for AWS it
integrates with common services such as
slack or chime so those could your
budget information will be pushed out to
there okay
hey this is Angie Brown from exam throat
and we are going to look at eight of
those budgets and this follow along and
learn how do you set our own budget so
we'll go ahead here and create our
budget here alright and so we're gonna
be presented with you there a class
budget a usage budget or a reservation
budget so I'm going to choose cost and
we're gonna set your budget and so they
give you a suggestion like a monthly ec2
budget okay and I could just say all my
cost so overall overall costs okay and
then we can choose the period so monthly
seems good to me but you have monthly
quarterly and annually here all right
you can have a recurring budget or
expiring we want this for every single
month and then you can choose your
budget amount so we have a fixed or a
monthly a budget planning this is a
little bit more complicated so I guess
if you're a start-up and you assumed
your costs were going up you want to
fill this go up and up now
or if you were a seasonal business and
you assumed your budget would change
based on the demand it would definitely
make sense to a set monthly budget
planning okay but we'll go back to fixed
here and we can just have a cost you can
see it shows my last month cost was $126
let's just say I wanted my cost to
always be $100 per month it will draw
this line here and give me an idea of
whether I'm over or under okay and we
could filter services so if I wanted to
go here I could just choose ec2 okay and
I'm just going to look for ec2 I'm not
sure why I didn't show up and search
let's do already yes instead because
that was a bit easier to find here so
I'll apply filter so but just an idea to
show you just how that works there okay
and I'm just going to remove that filter
there if I could figure that out there
we are okay and we'll just apply that
filter again and we do have some
Advanced Options there but everything
seems pretty good so I'm just gonna go
ahead and configure alerts okay and so
you can get alerted if you're if you go
over the budget so you can get it based
on the actual cost that were forecasted
I would get so many emails if I or at
least I'd always get a email if I had
forecasted because forecast I'm within
my counter always spiked okay
but I here you could set the alert
threshold so when you're approaching
that budget so let's say you're 80% on
the way there it should send you an
email and then you would add your
contact here so I could just say Andrew
at exam pro dotco okay um maybe I've did
that button yeah just the one there okay
and you could also notify via Amazon SNS
so if you already have a topic arm you
could provide that there but apparently
you do not have to do that here which is
kind of nice but apparently they have a
new feature which is the chat bot so I'm
suppose if you were using slack you
could integrate that alert there so
nothing super exciting there but yeah so
if you were using slack or I'm sure it
integrates with a business version of
slack which is called chyme there's
probably another service there so that's
kind of interesting there but we'll go
ahead and we will confirm our budget
we're gonna get an overview of that and
we'll go ahead and create that budget
okay and so now we have this budget
and we just have to wait some time
before we can actually see some
information here but generally what
would happen is it will well here we go
I just did a refresh there so it showed
my budgeted my forecasted the current
versus budgeted and then the forecast
okay so yeah there you go that is a
DuBose budgets so I just wanted to show
you that the email here came through for
eight bits budgets and just what it
looks like so here you can see that it
says that I exceeded the amount of $80
so when we entered in that 80 percent it
calculated the dollar amount for us
there I just shows us that information
okay so there you go that's all you need
to know for those budgets hey this is an
exam Pro and we are looking at the TCO
calculator which stands for the total
cost of ownership and this allows you to
estimate how much you would save when
moving to a to us from on-premise so it
provides you a detailed set of reports
that can be used in executive
presentations the tool is built on
underlying calculation models that
generate fair assessments of value that
you can achieve given the data provided
okay and the TCO helps by reducing the
need need to invest in large capital
expenditures of course this tool is for
approximation purposes only so it's
really a persuasion tool to use for at
the executive level okay the idea is
that you would just launch the TCO
calculator you describe your environment
you're gonna get a three year summary of
cost comparisons and then you can
download that detailed report okay all
right so we're gonna take a look at in
this fall along the total cost of
ownership calculator here so just google
and find your way to the TCO calculator
on AWS when you arrive this page you
know you're in the right place and
you're gonna be looking for this big
yellow button now it does take sometimes
quite a bit of time for this to load so
I've already clicked that button and
have it open here on a new tab okay and
so you'd get here and the IDS you choose
your currency we're gonna stay with US
Dollars and you can choose whether
you're on the premise or collocation
we're gonna stay on Prem
you can decide whether they are physical
servers or virtual machines you can see
some options there and now you're going
to go ahead and fill some stuff in here
so let's see if I can figure something
out here that is a good example so maybe
you'd have a non database server so you
have your web application okay and let's
say it is using loops it is using the
number of VMs you have six running and
each have I don't know eight cores and
you're using that's 102 for 204 204 8
amount of memory oh that's gigabytes
whoo that's too high we'll just say 8
gigabytes there ok we can choose the
hypervisor the OS there I'm gonna add
another row here and we'll choose a
database as time and we'll just say
Postgres here ok we'll say Postgres and
maybe we don't have as many post-grad
servers running here so we'll say 2 and
we will say 4 cores and we will say 4
gigabytes of memory here and the spring
on vmware and then we can choose storage
here so we have some storage here I
guess we could just put something in
here so we could say we'd have 500
gigabytes maybe 500 gigabytes of storage
ok and so now that we have all those
things we're gonna go ahead and hit
calculate the TCL and we are just going
to wait here for this report to generate
alright alright so after a little late
there we can see this report has
generated and we have a comparison
between on-prem and AWS and it's saying
that we could save up to 78% a year
which would give us a total savings of
$200,000 over the course of three years
ok so here we got a cost breakdown and
we get the total cost of ownership there
so we have the server the storage the
network and now we have this additional
cost which is i2 labor ok because this
is in the case that you have on Prem
you're gonna have to hire IT to manage
the infrastructure on AWS it's it's
taken care of for you ok so you're not
paying for that cost and then it shows
you your on-prem environment and then it
shows you the equivalent in AWS so if
you had if this is what you're using
this is what you'd want to use on AWS ok
and then down below we have some
additional information okay and then we
have a cost breakdown so it just
compares those breakdowns for you okay
and then we got other things here like
calculations oh boy that's a lot of
stuff methodology okay so a lot of stuff
that you can use within a presentation
to make the case to move to AWS okay and
then up here we can just download that
report okay and that would download it
as a PDF all right but there you go so
that's the the TCO calculator
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Ava's landing zone
which helps enterprises quickly set up a
secure Avis multi account now I have
enterprises in red there because if you
read the marketing page it doesn't say
that it's for enterprises but it
definitely is because from what I
remember it has a very expensive upfront
cost okay which but for enterprises
would be a very little so it's not gonna
be for this small to medium size
startups but the purpose of Avis landing
zone is to provide you with a baseline
environment to get started with
multi-count architecture so what does
that mean well the idea is that you have
these companies and eight of us
recommends that you run in multi count
but they don't know how best to the
company itself doesn't know how best to
set up multi count and make sure it's
secure and and and good for future
growth and so landing zone is basically
that set up for you okay and the way
this all works is through a to account
vending machine also known as a VM which
automatically provisions and configures
new accounts via a service catalog
template and the way you're going to
access these accounts is going to be
using single sign-on okay and so the
environments here are customizable to
allow customers to implement their own
account baselines through a landing zone
configuration and update pipeline okay
so now that we have an idea let's go
take a peek at the landing zone page so
here we are on the ADA's landing zone
marketing page I just want to scroll
down here for you so I can just show you
that they have some architectural
diagrams here
give you an idea what you are getting
with landing zone so here it says the
solution includes four counts add-on
products can be deployed using a tuba
Service Catalog so when you get this
you're gonna get four counts are gonna
get this master count here then you're
gonna have a shared service account log
archive account security counts so when
you are setting up your eight of us
organizations you should always have a
logging account and should also also
have a security account that are isolate
from your other accounts because it's
just good for for auditing purposes okay
and so eight of us is giving you the
best setup possible by doing that for
you all right and so when you need
additional counts then you use that
account vending machine okay and so that
account vending machine will just create
new accounts for you and so that's
really all you need to know about a
landing zone that it is giving you a
baseline environment and then it's going
to allow you to add additional accounts
that are going to be secured with a lot
of other good best practices baked into
it okay
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at Ava's resource
groups and tagging so we've got two
different things here but they are
strongly related so we need to learn
them both at the same time so tags are
words or phrases that act as metadata
for organizing your aid abuse resources
and then you have resource groups are a
collection of resources that share one
or more tags okay and so the way you'd
access those resource groups is there's
a drop down right beside services where
you get to create a group and manage
your tags okay so the whole purpose of
resource groups is to help you organize
and solid eight information based on
your your project and the resources that
you use and resource groups can display
details about a group of resources based
on metrics alarms configuration settings
okay and at any time you can modify the
settings of your resource groups to
change what a resources appear okay so
let's say you had a database a server
and maybe an s3 bucket and you wanted to
group them all together you'd give them
all the same tag and then you could put
them in a resource group and so that
the concept there okay so in this fall
along here I'm going to show you how you
use resource groups and tagging so we're
gonna spin up a couple of servers give
them some tags and associate those to a
resource group see that they are in a
group and then we'll turn down those
servers okay so what I want to do is
make your way to ec2 so we'll go to
services at the top here and type in ec2
okay and we'll just make our way over to
the ec2 console so once we are here
we'll have to go ahead and launch some
instances so let's press the big blue
button okay and now that we're in here
we'll just choose Amazon Linux - okay
and we'll stick with the micro tier
because that is the free tier and then
we're just gonna set up two servers okay
and we're going to go on to storage and
pass onto storage onto tags and we're
gonna add a new tag and I'm gonna call
it project and I say Terok Nor okay
Terok Nor and that is a Star Trek
reference if you're wondering okay and
we don't have to worry about screw
groups we'll have to review and launch
we're gonna hit launch here and I'm
going to drop down pursue without a key
pair we're not doing anything with these
servers just tagging them okay and so
they are launching we're gonna go down
to view instances in the right hand side
there and then they are launching I'm
just going to click on one of these even
though there's a loading thing you can
still click the check box and we're
gonna go tags here just so we can see
our tag and then what I want you to do
is drop resource groups down here and
I'm just gonna create a new group I'm
gonna open a new tab to make my life a
little bit easier here I will just wait
for this to load okay and so here we are
creating a new group and we need to
choose our group types that we have
tagged based and CloudFormation stack
based so we're gonna be going with tag
based today okay and so then we have our
grouping criteria this is gonna
determine how things will be grouped and
so we can choose a resource type but
we'll just leave it to all supported
resource types okay so that allows it to
be anything you see - or anything okay
and we will need to supply our tags so
going back over here I just want to make
sure it's 100
the same so I'm just gonna copy and
paste that there so we got project and
then we have Terok Nor okay and I'm just
gonna hit add and so now we have our
criteria set up this is where we would
see those group resources we don't see
any as of yet okay I'm just gonna click
here to see what we'd see oh sorry so
you hit that there and now those
instances have been found and also the
volumes the EBS volumes attached there
also have the tag applied it appears to
be so we actually have four resources
and that's why and so I'm just going to
type in Terok Nor here okay and we have
some optionals here to tag the actual
group here that's not necessary we'll
just hit create group okay and so now we
have grouped resources okay so whenever
we want to look at our saved groups okay
we can go here we can see Terok Nor and
we can see all the resources and then
quickly click through to find of the
resources with those tags alright
alright and so now that we know how to
create a resource group let's actually
go look at manage tags okay cuz this is
a very convenient way to find resources
all right based on tag so what we can do
is we it's certain it adds the region
that we're in so we're in Ohio right now
and we could choose the type of resource
I'll say all resource types and I'm
gonna just type in project see how it
autocompletes there and I can just Terok
Nor okay I'm gonna add and then hit
search resources okay and so what that
has done for me is it's actually found
them all for me and if I want to export
them as a CSV those resources I could do
so and I think about check box here and
go to manage tags selected resources I
can now remove the tag from all these
resources here or add additional tags
okay so I can go here and then say
Federation Starfleet okay alright and I
believe if I hit review and apply tags
it's going to go now apply those tags to
those four resources so we go back to
ec2 instance here we might have to do a
manual refresh up here and so now we
have an additional tag applied if we
wanted to remove those on mass it's
going to be the same story right so
we're gonna go to a project we're going
to go to Terok Nor
we're going to hit all resources here
search for those resources and I can
select them all manage them and remove
that tag okay so yeah it's pretty darn
straight for it I think I actually
removed our original tag there so if I
go back here and do a refresh now we
just have Federation Starfleet okay so
you know that's as simple as it is and
there's tagging found out throat so many
services within AWS okay and I'm just
going to go and shut down these
instances because we are done with them
so we want to terminate them we want to
say yes okay and so that's Oliver clean
up there so there you go hey this is
Andrew Brown from exam Pro and we are
looking at AWS quickstarts which are
pre-built templates by a Daboo solution
architects and amos partners to help you
deploy popular stacks on AWS and so the
benefit here is that it can reduce
hundreds of manual procedures into just
a few steps
okay so QuickStart is composed of three
parts so you're gonna get a reference
architecture for the deployment so it's
gonna be like an architectural diagram
and description and then the actual
QuickStart itself is just a cloud
formation template and cloud formation
templates are used for provisioning
multiple ADA's resources so it's gonna
automatically that deployment for you
and it will have also a deployment guide
explaining the architecture and
implementation in detail ok so most
quick starts a reference reference
deploy deployments enable you to spin up
a fully functional architecture in less
than an hour ok so you can get
operational pretty quick with these
things and on the right hand side there
you can see that I've cherry-picked went
out there from Annika and that's one is
for setting up an IOT camera connector
ok so here I just want to give you a
quick tour of Ava's quick starts just so
you have an idea of what there is
available to you here and so on the
left-hand side we have a bunch of
filtration options to choose or to
narrow down some nice templates here for
us and on the right hand side we already
have some templates so let's go into
analytics here and right away we have a
one here by Cambridge technology which
automatically deploys at clickstream
analytics
and for you so that sounds pretty cool
so if we just click into this actual
QuickStart here what we're gonna see
down below is that architectural diagram
I was talking about how well like a
bunch of descriptions as to what it is
doing this stuff varies based on a
QuickStart templates that don't expect
to see the same stuff everywhere but
they'll generally give you instructions
on how to deploy and then the cost or
licences involved and so if we wanted to
launch this we go view deployment guide
details maybe here okay and oh we got a
big white paper so this one's a bit
different here sometimes the buttons are
a little more clear oh yeah here it is
so again this will vary based on each
one so I've never done this one before
but we'll say deploy into a new V PC
okay
and what that's gonna do is set up that
CloudFormation template for use that's
what I'm expecting anyway so yep there
it is it's going into CloudFormation
okay and we're not going to go through
this whole process I'm just showing you
at least to this stage okay and so here
we have that template we would go next
and I'm just gonna see if it asks us to
provide some information so yeah these a
confirmation template has a bunch of
variables that you'd fill in so based on
the QuickStart template you have it's
just going to have different options
here as you can see this one has a
variety of options but we would just
fill that in go next review and launch
and then it would spin up that
clickstream for us so there you go that
is hey this is Andy Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at AWS cost and usage
report and this is a service which will
generate out a detailed spreadsheet
enabling you to better analyze and
understand your eight of his costs so
just as it says you have a big button
and you download a spreadsheet and there
you get a nice big break down the report
gets placed in an s3 bucket you can use
Athena to turn that report into a Kruger
Bowl database or or you can use quick
site to visualize your billing data as
graphs okay so you have a lot of options
here to work with this data alright but
maybe you just want the spreadsheet okay
so
Ava's coffee usage and report so in this
all along I just want to show you how to
use a Tubbs cost a nuisance report to
get that spreadsheet okay and so what
you're gonna do is you're gonna go up
the top right corner here you're gonna
go to my billing dashboard and you're
gonna make your way to the cost and
usage reports here on the left hand side
okay and then once you get here we're
gonna have a nice big blue button that
we can press to create our reports let's
go ahead and do that so we're gonna need
to give this a name so we to say my my
used to cost of usage okay and we can
include additional resource IDs here I'm
gonna just hit next and then we need to
configure where it goes so I'm gonna
create a new bucket so I'm just going to
say exp for example cost and usage okay
and it's going to put that in the US
East one region there okay I will hit
next and we have this nice big policy at
once we'll say save that okay and then
we can choose to what detail that we
want I'll leave it for hourly that's
total right now we'll say daily that's
probably more ideal there and we'll
create a new version of this report and
now for easy integration we do have
those options that are thenar read
shipping quick site but we are just
going to leave this as be I'm gonna make
a zip because I want to make my life
really easy here because if I download
to my local Imperial and be able to
unzip that with a very little effort
here I'm gonna hit next and what we can
do here is go hit review and complete
okay and so now it is going to deliver
that so in the next 24 hours your first
report will be delivered to an Amazon s3
bucket you configured during this report
creation so we're just gonna have to
wait for this creation and I will come
back here and download and show you that
report okay alright so it's been 24
hours and I went over to my s3 buckets
here and I search for that bucket that I
created and then I just drilled down so
if you just click through to that bucket
okay so I go into here and then there's
this folder that has no name okay and
then you go to the costs and usage and
then you go into here then you're gonna
another folder you click into there and
then we can get that CSV zip okay and so
that's going to have a zip which
contains a CSV file and that's going to
give us that raw data which I've opened
up here in Excel and so you can see
there's a lot of data here and so it's
up to you to make sense of this data but
at least you can see you get all the raw
data from costs and usage and of course
I mean the huge advantage here is that
you can integrate this into a quick site
and Athena to analyze it with an AWS ok
so there you go that is the costume
usage hey this is Angie Brown from exam
Pro and we're looking at organizations
and accounts so when you first sign up
for AWS you are creating a single
account and that first user you're
logging in as is the root user ok so
just look over here on this diagram see
where we have a master account so just
let's pretend that this was the account
that we created and we are logging in is
that root account user so what you can
do is you can promote your account into
an organization and so what's that's
going to allow you to do it's going to
allow you to create multiple accounts
within that organization so now that
original account is now a master account
and underneath it you can create
multiple accounts ok so why would you
want to do this well if you're an
organization you might want to like
isolate different departments within
your company and also to have fine-tuned
control over what they have access to on
mass ok so the idea here is like let's
say you have a development team on one
side and there's multiple accounts you
can put them within our organizational
unit and then use a service control
policy to apply rules about what
services that can and cannot use on mass
ok so I mean that's pretty much all
there is to it but I think this would be
a lot more clear when we do a quick
follow along ok
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
into this fall long I'm going to show
you how to use organizations and create
some member accounts okay so there are
two places where you can manage your
organization it's within the IM console
here so you just type in IM to get to
that console but you can see here that
it says organization is not in use
because we have yet to create an
organization so what we'll have to do is
in a new tab we'll have to go to the
organization's console here which is
where I am at currently and we have the
sense little wizard here to get started
so I'm gonna go ahead here and hit
create organization it's going to ask us
to create an organization where we have
all these features or we could just have
one with good solid a billing we
definitely want to create this one here
so I'm gonna hit create organization
great and so here I have created an
organization and you can see that it
sent me an email to finish verifying
your master account because the original
account we have here has now been turned
into a master account so I'm gonna go
ahead and just go confirm that email
here so now I'm in my email here and
here's that verification email so I'm
just gonna go ahead and press that
button and now this has been verified
okay so I'm just gonna close that here
and I'm just going to refresh and you
can see we are now verified ok and we
can see that's our master account I
think it might be up the star emphasizes
that that is a master account so if I go
back to I'm console here and do a
refresh let's see if there's any kind of
change okay and there definitely is so
you can see that we have a root
organization here and then we have the
exam Pro fresh account which is of the
master account so we can't create
additional accounts from here it's just
more of an organizational structure but
what we can do is go back to the
organization's console here and do some
organized organizing so before I
actually go ahead and create any
accounts let's actually go look at some
some organizations we're sorry to
organize this account so we'll go to
organize accounts and so over here this
is where we'd see all of our accounts
and we can create some organizational
units so I'm going to create a new
organizational unit called developers
okay
and so now I have that organizational
unit and there is some way for me to set
them in the tree actually by default has
already set it here so we already have
that okay so I suppose it already is
associated to the root there okay and so
now what we'll want to do is we want to
actually create an account under this
organizational unit so let's go back to
accounts here let's make a new account
I'm gonna create a new account here and
I'm gonna do andrew plus fresh plus
developer at exam Pro Co here okay has
it's got to be here and we'll just say
Andrew Brown ok because every account
has to have a unique unique email for
the root account and there is this IM
role I'm just gonna leave that blank and
hit create and what's that what that is
going to do it's going to get a set up
with a new account and so I'm just
waiting here for this to send us an
email to tell us that our account is
ready okay so we'll just wait here for a
little bit alright so after waiting a
few minutes here I got a new email
saying my account is ready okay and just
back in here if you do a hard refresh
here you'll see that the account is set
up you probably don't want to name the
account based on someone's name I just
inherently had put my name in there
generally you'd want to name this
developers or whatever the account is
called here but this account is now
ready so how do we actually access this
account well the way you do it is you
actually just log in as the root user so
I'm gonna just close this tab here and I
need to remember what this email is here
so it's andrew plus fresh + developer
and we're just going to log out here and
just sign back in with this as the root
user so what we'll do here is we'll just
go ahead and go sign in to console and
we are just going to provide that email
there and we're just going to hit next
okay and what we're gonna do is we're
actually gonna hit forgot password this
is the only way to set up new accounts
you have to just reset the password and
so we have to enter in this code v 3y m
QQ that's really hard to see but i think
that's what it is
okay we'll try this again 8 7 e 8y p
great and so now we're gonna get an
email here and so we'll just wait for
that email okay alright and so here is
that email to reset our password so we
just got to go ahead here and click this
link here okay and so now we're just
gonna have to provide a new password so
I'm just going to fill something in
there okay and so now our password has
been reset great so now we'll just have
to proceed to sign in here so we'll just
put in that new password and we should
be in our new account great and so now
we are in wit within this new account so
it's not easy to get new account set up
and so I guess the next thing is we'll
look at how we can organize this account
with our organization so we're gonna
have to log in and go back into the root
account of our master account okay so
that's what I'm just doing here okay so
I believe I called it fresh and we will
just supply that a password okay and so
what we'll do here is we'll make our way
over to organizations and we see we have
our account there and so what we want to
do is we want to add our account to an
organizational unit and so I'm just
going to see how we can do that if I can
remember how so I'm just going to check
box this here and I believe over here if
we right click here this account is
currently in the routes to move this
choose the move account option okay so I
guess that's what we need to do here so
we'll just click on move and we will
just choose that to be in the developers
route and so now this account is under
the developers organizational unit okay
so if we click in there we can see that
account so the reason you'd want to move
things into organizational units is so
you can attach policies okay and service
control policies and that's what they
are helps you a limit access to certain
resources so if we only wanted that
account to only be allowed to use ec2
that's what we can do so
we'd say only ec2 here as the policy
name and then we'll just filter out what
it is that we want to allow so we'll say
ec2 and then we have to choose actions
so we'll say all okay and then we can
move on to resources I suppose specify
the resource type ec2 we'll say all
resources here and then we'll hit add
and then we'll move on to the conditions
and so we don't need to change any of
this here I'm pretty sure I'm happy with
that
and we're gonna say allow so we're just
going to allow access to all of ec2 okay
so that way everything else would be
implicitly denied so the only thing
we'll have access to is ec2 and
hopefully the statement is valid and
we'll just go hit create policy and now
that we have our policy created here
which gives us only ec2 access we now
can apply it to that organization you
have to do everything from the root so
you'd have to enable service control
policies so that you're allowed to use
them okay and so now that is enabled and
I believe if we go into developers we
should be able to set that policy so
I'll go here and I'm gonna just choose
attach okay and I'm not sure if I can
detach it but let's give it a go okay
and so now this one should only have
access to ec2 and but the root will
still have access to everything okay so
there we go so now that we have an idea
how we can apply permissions to accounts
let's actually go back to the other
account and just go ahead and just shut
it down or terminate it because we're
not going to be using this other account
for anything we don't want to leave this
other account laying around okay so what
we'll do is we will just log out here
and I'm just going to log back into this
other account okay so I'm just
proceeding to login to that other
account there yeah and I just got to
type the password in here okay great so
we're back into our member account there
and we did say we were only allowed to
launch ec2 so actually let's go ahead
and try to just create something else
just to see if our servers control
policy is working and right away so
you're not authorized to perform Blaine
so our policy is working as expected
okay and I didn't mention this before
but every time you create an account
they all have their own root account ok
so right now we are logged in as the
root account into this member account
and let's say you want to get rid of
this account you can actually suspend
this account so let's go ahead and do
that now so I believe to a suspend
accounts we have to go to up here and
we'll have to go to my account alright
so but there's only one problem here is
the fact that we don't actually have the
ability to close our own account because
we don't have the permission so we're
going to have to go back into our master
account and give us better permissions
there so we can actually go ahead and
get rid of this account so I'm just
going to log out here we're gonna go
back into our master account there and
we'll make our way back to organisations
here and so you might think that you
could just remove the account here but
the problem with that is that it would
just leave the organisation and in order
to leave the organisation you'd have to
attach a new credit card and the account
wouldn't be what actually wouldn't be
deleted or suspended you actually can't
delete accounts in AWS you can just
suspend them which make sure that no
resources are being billed for with
those accounts anymore and that's what
we want to accomplish here so we're
gonna go back to our organisation
accounts here we're going to click on
developers and we're going to go to
service policies and I'm going to attach
the full access and then detach only ec2
and we're gonna log out and go back into
that member account alright so here we
are going back into that member account
and we'll just - was it Andrew + exam
pro + developers
oh no it's fresh ok fresh + developers
at exam proko maybe it's just developer
there we go we'll enter that password in
ok great and so now we should be able to
get rid of our account here so I'm going
to go up and go to my account ok and so
we do have some sensitive information
here which I have blocked out but within
here we are going
to go ahead and close her account so
we'll just do that so what I did here is
I just scrolled all the way to the
bottom and you can see that we can close
our account and we have a big long
disclaimer about it but again the
advantage here of closing our account
which just suspends it is that it's
going to ensure that we are not being
billed for anything else within our
account okay and I'm just gonna go ahead
here and say I understand for the three
things here and go ahead and close my
account
and so this account has now been closed
and I can just proceed to logging out
here so just scroll up and just log out
and we'll go back into our master
account alright and so now we'll just go
ahead and log back into our master
account and go just check on the status
of that organisation and we will just
make our way back to organisations here
and you can see now this is suspended so
this account is no longer active okay
and so that's all there is to it okay so
yeah that's Avis organizations and yeah
there is some some visibility there are
organizations within the IM console
there's not a lot there to do you can
just see the structure and look at
service control policies but just be
aware that each of us is developing that
in I am hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we are going to learn a bit
about any of us networking here so I
have this nice big architectural diagram
and we're gonna work our way through it
okay so the first thing you'll want to
do when you want to launch resources
you're gonna have to choose a region to
launch them in and so a region is a
geographical location of your network so
that could be us East one which is North
Virginia or maybe you would choose
Canada Central which is based in
Montreal once you've decided what region
you want to launch resources in you're
gonna need a V PC and a V PC stands for
virtual private cloud it is a logical
isolated section of the Avis cloud where
you can launch any business resources so
it's just a slice of the ADA based
network just for you okay and then once
you have your V PC you're going to
- sub divided up into subnets and so
subnets are a logical partition of IP
network into multiple smaller network
segments okay so you could have public
and private subnets the difference
between a public and a private subnet a
public one is generally accessible to
the Internet whereas a private subnet is
where it is not okay so when you have
things that need to be super secure are
you gonna put those in a private subnet
all right
and so subnets are defined within an
availability zone and an availability
zone is just a data center for your
where your going to launch your AWS
resources and those aces are contained
or specific to specific regions okay so
now we have a region we have a VP see we
have our subnets and so we can go ahead
and start launching resources into our
subnets here so we could launch an ec2
instance or an RDS instance but how how
is that ec2 instance going to reach the
Internet so in order to do so we're
gonna need a gateway to the Internet and
that's where Internet gateway comes into
play so it enables access to the
Internet you can think of it as a door
to the internet off from your V PC
outward okay but just how the internet
gateway is not enough because the subnet
has to know how to reach that internet
gateway to reach the Internet and that's
where our route tables come in so route
tables determine where network traffic
from your subnets are to are directed so
you'd create a route in your row table
to say hey
row table go here and go out to the
Internet alright now that we have a way
to the Internet and we can launch
resources into our subnets what about
security and that's where security
groups and knackles are going to come in
so security groups is acts as a firewall
at the instance level so here you can
see that we have an ec2 instance an RDS
and they span subnets and we have a
border drawn around it to say that the
security group is protecting those two
instances so that's how that works and
you have knackles and knackles is
another form of security but it's at the
subnet level so it sits in front of
subnets and controls access in and out
of those okay so I mean those
the most important components of a dubis
networking there's definitely a lot more
that's all we need to know for now okay
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at database services
and so you can see we have a variety of
different services for databases on AWS
and for the actual exam you probably
just need to know dynamodb RDS Aurora
and a redshift but when you're taking
the exam they might throw in these other
ones to just throw you off and so by
knowing all of them through process of
elimination you can determine what the
correct answer is okay so I think it's
going to be good for us to learn them
all and so just starting at the top here
with dynamodb which is a no SQL key
value database and so I always like to
say that it's Cassandra like or
Cassandra based because I think at one
point it was or at least it is very
similar to it and so this is a very flat
and simple database which can scale to
millions of records and will give you a
guarantee of read and writes per second
okay so if you needed to say 200 reads
per second you just enter that in and
you'd get a guarantee of it alright
moving on to document DB which is a no
SQL document database that is MongoDB
compatible so if you need MongoDB you're
gonna be using document DB then we have
RDS which stands for the relational
database service okay and it's probably
the most popular database on AWS and the
most commonly used and it supports
multiple engines so you can use MySQL
Postgres Mario DB Oracle or Microsoft
SQL Server alright and it happens to
have a one other engine called Aurora
and sorority is really its own thing and
it is a fully managed relational
database okay
and within it you can choose to either
run MySQL or Postgres and so because
it's fully managed it has a greater
performance over the regular my school
Postgres RDS and you're gonna see my
school it has a better performance of up
to five times whereas Postgres has up to
three times now Aurora again is highly
available and
horrible and so when it when you spin up
an Aurora cluster it's going to be
running six copies of your database
across three availability zones okay so
with that it definitely is more
expensive than using RDS but if you are
an enterprise or you need that guarantee
of availability and durability you're
definitely going to want to use Aurora
now I'm moving on to R or serverless
it's pretty much the same thing as
Aurora with less features but the huge
advantage here is that it's it's way
more inexpensive so this is kind of like
a relational database where it's on a
need B basis okay so the idea is that
you're only paying for when you're using
it just like kind of like a lambda okay
and it's really good for development
workloads or web apps that are not
frequently used or if you're using a
service architecture okay so it makes it
really easy to connect lambdas to a Roth
server list now moving on to Neptune it
is a managed graphic database that's all
you need to know then we're on to a
redshift so redshift is a columnist or
database okay so instead of reading via
Rose it reads via columns and so it's
really really good working with a huge
amount of data where you need to
generate maybe and like reports or
analytics like a business intelligence
tool and it can handle petabytes worth
of data
okay so there's like a thousand
terabytes in one petabyte so that is a
significant amount of data
moving on to ElastiCache it is a caching
solution so you can either choose to use
the open source caching databases here
Redis or memcache okay so if you need
caching that's going to be your choices
here so there you go that's all the
database services
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at provisioning and
so provisioning is just an easy way to
set up a bunch of a diverse resources
for you or your servers in an automated
way and this could be done via code or
it could be done via a graphical user
interface okay and so each of us has a
variety of different services that help
us with provisioning so let's just learn
the difference between all these
services starting with elastic Beanstalk
so elastic Beanstalk is really good at
deploying web applications where you
don't have to think about the underlying
infrastructure at all so what you're
gonna do is you're just gonna prepare
your code you're gonna upload it to lots
of Beanstalk choose the container you
want to use with the language of choice
and it will more or less work with very
little to no configuration so if you're
using Ruby on Rails you just choose the
Ruby container upload your code it would
work and you know if you wanted to use
Jango then you just choose the Python
container etc etc okay I like to think
of elastic Beanstalk as the Heroku for
AWS have you ever used Heroku it's just
a service where you not part of AWS but
you just upload your code and it just
works okay moving on to opsworks
Officeworks is a configuration
management service and it's going to
help you the management help you with
the configuration of your instances
using either chef or puppet so those are
just two different two developer tools
that you can use to manually or sari
pragmatically set up a server so for for
chef you're actually using Ruby that's
what it's written in and so you would
define these things called recipes and
those recipes would go out and set up
things on your actual ec2 server so if
you had to install dependencies or pull
the code or do a bunch of other stuff
that's what those tools are going to do
and opsworks also has a constant called
layers so you can define your
infrastructure as like three tier or two
tier layers and so you could have like
an application layer a database
and networking layer that just makes
things very clear okay moving on to
cloud formation cloud formation is
infrastructure as code and so the idea
here is that you are creating a JSON or
Yambol file and what you're going to do
is you're going to define all of your
ADA bills resources that you want to
provision and how exactly how you want
to configure them you're going to upload
that template and then it's going to set
everything up for you in one go
okay so cloud formation is an extremely
powerful provisioning tool and so
compared to office works also works has
some limitations as to what it can do so
it can set up some things for you but
confirmation can do anything pretty much
in AWS okay so it is the most complex
option but it is also the most flexible
option in our provisioning toolset here
moving on to Ava's quick starts these
are just pre-made packages which
actually are just cloud formation
templates and they are created by AWS or
with AWS third-party providers through
the APN network okay and so they are
going to have these prepackaged
templates for a variety of different
things and we do cover quicks our
QuickStart in more detail here in this
course but the idea is like let's say
you wanted to get started with ml you'd
go to the ml category and there would be
a bunch of pre-made configure
conformation templates and you just
launch one okay so you'd have to take a
look to see what there is there but it
is a provisioning tool moving on to a
TMS marketplace this is a digital
catalog of thousands of software
listings from independent software
vendors where you can find buy test and
deploy software ok and so generally
you're gonna be using the marketplace to
buy managed ec2 instances so let's say
you needed to set up a wordpress you
could go into this marketplace and find
an ami for WordPress so one that is very
popular is by--but Nami and so the
advantage here is that it's just
pre-configured for you and maybe it has
additional security hardening and so you
would pay a monthly subscription to use
that ok so those are all of our
provisioning options on AWS
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at computing services
on AWS
starting with ec2 which stands for lots
of compute cloud and you can see that
I've made a division there and that's
just to emphasize how important ec2 is
and the fact that basically every
service under the hood is using ec2 so
no matter what you're using whether it's
a lambda RDS or redshift they're all
running on ec2 instances they just what
might be abstracted away from you
because eight of us is managing those
ec2 instances okay and so what is ec2
well it's a highly configurable server
where you get to choose your CPU memory
network and operating system ok so now
moving on to the other computing
services we have ECS which stands for
elastic container service and this is
basically docker as a service so if you
need to run micro services or a a docker
eyes application you're going to be
launching it on ECS so with ECS what you
would do is you would just choose the
type of ec2 instance you you want and
that ec2 instance will come
pre-configured with docker running on it
and then it has a really nice interface
so that you would just define your
containers within something called a
task or a service and then you would
just run them on ECS ok next on this
list you have Fargate and this is also
for micro services and this is kind of
like the evolution of ECS so with ECS
you choose what ec2 instance you you
need to use for gate you don't choose
ec2 instance you just would define your
your containers within a task or a
service and you would just tell them to
run and AWS would just have it run ok
and so the difference here is that you
aren't paying for the ec2 instance
you're just paying for the runtime and
the CPU utilized ok so it's kind of like
lambdas where you're just paying for the
time performed and the resources used
okay moving on to eks which is
kubernetes as a service and so if you've
ever heard of kubernetes it's becoming
the de facto standard for micro services
within the industry and so since it's so
important AWS has decided
that it needs to have a service to run
kubernetes and it's called eks okay so
it gives you all the benefits of ECS
that allows you to run the open source
kubernetes okay and again this is just
for micro services moving on to lambda
lambda lets you run service functions so
the idea here is that it you just upload
your code in the form of function and it
just runs you don't have to think about
the server's there's nothing to
provision everything is taken care of
for you and you are just paying for the
compute time based on how long it runs
okay so that's all there is with lambda
okay I'm moving on to elastic Beanstalk
and so blossom Beanstalk is going to
orchestrate a various amounts of ATM
services for you so the idea is it will
set up ec2 as 3 SNS cloud watch RDS load
balancers whatever you need to run your
web application and the idea behind
elastic beanstalk it allows you to set
up developer environments that's what
it's intended for it's not really for
production use so the idea is like let's
say you're a developer and you have a
web app and it's running on ruby on
rails or Django or L'Oreal you just want
to get it running but you don't want to
have to think about all the services you
have to set up you just upload your code
to elastic Beanstalk it would do the
rest for you so that's all there is
there to that service and it really just
is using ec2 again so it's just going to
setup you to two instances for you but
you just don't have to worry about it
moving on to a doubles batch so a
dispatch as the name implies for batch
processing so you can plan scheduled and
execute your batch computing workloads
across the full range of Ava's compute
services and features and so what it's
doing is it's just launching ec2
instances for you using spot pricing so
that you can save a lot of money so
there you go that is all the computing
services you need to know
hey this is Angie Brown an exam pro and
on AWS we have a variety of different
storage services that are available to
us so let's quickly go through them so
the first one on our list here is s3
which stands for simple storage service
and it's an object store I like to think
of it as a hard drive in the cloud where
I don't have to think about the actual
hard drive I can just upload files and I
don't have to worry about running out of
space because there's unlimited space so
it really is a no-brainer ok and then
you have s3 glacier and so it's like s3
but it's extremely inexpensive but the
trade-off here is that you have to be ok
with waiting for several minutes up to
hours to access those files and when you
do access those files there is a
retrieval cost so it is a really good
use case for large enterprises who have
lots of sensitive data but they have to
hold onto it for 7 to 10 years but
they're very unlikely to actually ever
look at that data ok so that's where as
the glacier comes in then you have
storage gateway so I like to think of
Storage Gateway as an extension of your
on-premise storage into the cloud you
could also use Storage Gateway as a
backup solution so for your local
storage you would just back it up onto
s3 there ok and so basically storage
gateway is a hybrid solution for on-prem
to cloud for storage and then you have
EBS which stands for elastic block store
and this is essentially a virtual hard
drive in the cloud that you can attach
to ec2 instances and you get to choose
what kind of hard drive you want it to
be ok so if you want it to be a solid
state drive which are optimized for
higher I ops and better throughput or
you could use an H HD which is going to
be more inexpensive solution ok and then
you have EFS which stands for elastic
file storage and it is a file storage
solution so it's like having a file
system that you're able to mount to
multiple ec2 instances at the same time
whereas with elastic block store you're
only able to attach that to one ec2 so
that is a huge advantage there ok all
right and so now we're looking at
snowball and it is a way of moving a lot
of data around very quickly from your
on-premise network into AWS or
vice-versa so let's say you have
terabytes worth of data uploading that
directly to us would be extremely slow
and painful so what a ghost will do is
you order a snowball they'll send it to
you it's basically a computer in the
form of a suitcase with a lot of hard
drives in it and what you're going to do
is you're going to quickly load your
data onto that snowball and then it's
going to be delivered to AWS directly
into s3 ok and then we have snowball
edge which happens just to be like a
snowball with additional features and
more storage so it actually can also
process data as it's being inserted into
the snowball ok and then all last on our
list here is snowmobile which is super
cool and it allows you to move petabytes
worth of data so it's actually just a
giant cargo container or a shipping
container on a semi-trailer truck ok so
it's basically like a data center on
wheels so AWS will drive it to your
on-premise location and you're gonna
basically just hook up to that and
you're going to move all of your data
onto there and then it's going to be
driven back to AWS and then loaded into
s3 so there you go that is the storage
services of us
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam row
and we are looking at business centric
services so starting at the top of our
list here we have Amazon connect which
is a cloud-based call center service you
can set up in just a few clicks and
based on the same proven system used by
Amazon customer service teams ok so what
you can do with Amazon Connect is you
can accept inbound inbound calls and
dial
outbound you can record your calls and
then store them into s3 so maybe you
could then run them for analysis maybe
through Amazon comprehend or something
like that
and you can also set up workflows within
Amazon connect so if you want to route a
call based on a set of rules you can
definitely do that there next on our
list here is workspaces which just boils
down to being a virtual remote desktop
so secure managed services for
provisioning either windows or linux
desktops in just a few minutes which
quickly scales up to thousands of
desktops so you just would bring your
own license and you be able to spin up a
Windows 10 server that you can now log
in from the convenience of your a
doubles account okay then we have work
Docs which is a content creation
collaboration service easily create edit
and share content save essentially AWS
so this is a device's version of
SharePoint then you have chimes so this
is a double platform for online meetings
video conferencing and business business
calling which elastically scales to meet
your capacity needs so chime here is
like it's like having slack and also
Skype okay now we're on to work mail and
this is just managed business emails
contacts and calendar service which
supports for existing desktop and mobile
email client applications so this is
just Gmail for but like on AWS then you
have pinpoints so this is for marking
campaign management systems you can use
for sending targeted emails SMS push
notifications and voice messages so we
actually use a pin point here at exam
Pro to send out our campaign emails so
here you can import a bunch of contacts
create campaigns and do like a to be
testing on your your emails okay so
that's a useful tool there then you have
SES simple email service and this is a
cloud-based email sending service
designate for marketers and application
developers who send marketing
notification and emails so we just had
mentioned pin point which is for
marketing campaign management system and
this can send emails but SES is more for
like when you are building your web
application and you want to send out
emails from that application so let's
say you had someone who registered on
your platform and you want to send a
confirmation email you send them out
through SES at SES supports HTML emails
so there's another service called SNS
which also can send emails but that can
only send plain text so that's why SES
is more
for marketers because it has that HTML
component and last on our list is quick
site and this is a business intelligence
service and so the idea here is you can
connect multiple data sources and
quickly visualize data in the form of
graphs little to no programming
knowledge okay so you can connect a data
from s3 you're probably Aurora and RDS
and you just click it and then with a
bunch of other clicks you now have these
beautiful graphs okay and I believe that
there's also like an ml component in
quick site so there's a lot of cool
things you can do there and you can also
share those visualizations in the form
of dashboards to other people okay so
there you go those are the business
centric services hey this is Andrew
Brown from exam pro and we were looking
at enterprise integrations this is all
about going hybrid bringing your on-prem
and your eight abyss network together
okay so the first service we're gonna
look at here is Direct Connect and this
is a dedicated a gigabit network
connection from your on-premise to AWS
so imagine having a direct fiber optic
cable running straight to AWS so it's a
really good way of having low latency
and a dedicated connection okay the next
thing is VPN so the idea here is that it
can establish a secure connection to
your agents network and we have two ways
of doing this we have site-to-site VPN
and client VPN so site-to-site is when
you are connecting on prem to your
network and then you have Clym VPN so
imagine you have someone that works for
you
maybe they or maybe they work from home
and they have a laptop and you just want
to connect them to your network okay
then you have storage gateway so this is
a hybrid storage service that enables
your on-prem applications to use Ava's
cloud storage I always think of it as
extending your your on-prem hard drives
onto AWS so this can be also used for
backing up an archiving disaster
recovery cloud data processing storage
tiering and migration okay and then down
below we have Active Directory so we
have a team of directory service for
Microsoft Active Directory also known as
Avis managed Microsoft ad and this
enables your directory
we're workloads and Amos resources to
use managed Active Directory in the ADA
most cloud alright so I know that last
one is pretty boring but if you are
using Active Directory there are
definitely ways to integrate that with
AWS
hey this is Angie Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at to logging
services here we have cloud trail and
cloud walk starting with the cloud trail
it logs all API calls generally via the
SDK or eight of us CLI between a tubba
services so this is a really good
service to determine who we should blame
for something so if you wanted to say
who created this bucket who spun up that
expensive ec2 assets who launched the
sage maker notebook that's where cloud
trail is going to come into play and so
some of the other use cases here is that
we can use it to detect developer miss
configuration which we just talked about
but we could also use it to detect
malicious actors so if someone got into
our account cloud trail is going to
maybe give us an idea what is going on
and then we could also automate
responses so maybe every time someone
created a bucket you wanted to trigger
something and so that is something that
we could do maybe with cloud watch
events using cloud trail okay so now on
to cloud watch so claw watch is a
collection of multiple services but
generally when people say cloud watch
we're talking about cloud watch logs and
all the other plot watch services are
really based off the logs okay so cloud
watch logs is just a durable storage
solution for your logs and so logs could
be performance data about your a tubba
services such as CPU utilization memory
or network in you could also store your
application logs here so if you are
running Ruby on Rails you could send the
logs there or nginx just as that as well
or let's say you're using lambda at
lambda you would you can put within your
functions a lot of console log calls and
so that would then pass that on to cloud
watch and that is just in itself
application logs for lambdas okay and so
moving on to the other cloud watch
services we have metrics and they
represent a time or
set of data points and so you want to
think of Klawock metrics as a variable
to monitor and if that's still confusing
just think of it as like taking data
from cloud walks logs and turning it
into a graph okay then you have a cloud
watch events and this allows you to
trigger an event based on a condition so
when when you have log data or you could
trigger it based off of a metric or
other other kind of rules but like the
most common thing you might use cloud
watch events for is let's say every hour
you want to take a snapshot of your
elastic block store but like the volume
that is attached to your server you can
do that with cloud watch events then you
have cloud watch alarms and these
trigger notifications based on a metric
and so you would specify threshold and
when that threshold is breached that
alarm gets triggered and then it would
send you an email or a text message
however you specify okay then you have
cloud watch dashboards and this just
creates visualizations based off a
metric so when I said earlier that
metrics you could think of them as
graphs that's exactly what they are and
so you could take those graphs and then
put them onto a dashboard so you could
represent a lot of data at a glance so
there you go those are the two logging
services in AWS hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and we were looking at
know your initialisms and so there's a
lot of 80 bus services and some other
things that are represented by the short
form of initials and the reason why it's
good to know these is that on the exam
if they were to just give you the full
name of the service it might give away
the answer so they might use the
initialized version okay so if you had a
question about sending emails and when
the options was SES and you knew the e
stood for email that's a dead giveaway
of what the correct answer is it's also
just gonna help you comprehend things a
lot faster if every time you see auto
skeleton groups
you just think ASG because in your mind
you're gonna read that a lot quicker
okay so we do have a lot of initialisms
here and for services but there's also
some things
Tamm which is actually a type of person
that gets assigned your account or we
have IOT which is just a more generic
technology term which stands for
Internet of Things okay so there just
are a lot of things on here and these
are the most common ones that I could
think of and so I figured you know you
should study up on these and just make
sure you are familiar with them okay
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the shared
responsibility model and this is gonna
deal with security oven in the cloud so
when we're talking about customers they
are responsible for security in the
cloud so what does that mean well
whatever data you put on AWS you are
responsible for it so if you do not
secure it that is your fault or if you
do not turn on monitoring services to
monitor sensitive data that's going to
be your fault as well or there's a
variety of different eight of those
services that you can use and it's up to
you to configure them so if there is a
miss configuration that fault is going
to be with you okay so those are your
responsibilities then we have AWS and so
any of us is responsible for the
security of the cloud so the hardware
the operations of managed services and
the global infrastructure okay so all
the things you can't touch is what AWS
is responsible for and so this is
actually just a pared down version of
the share responsibility model the full
one actually looks like this okay and so
you can just see that there's a lot more
information here so for the customer we
got customer data platforms application
I am OS the network the fire
configuration client side dating
encryption server-side encryption
network traffic protection and then AWS
we have software and hardware right so
for the software you have your compute
your storage your database your
networking and for your hardware you
have and they base global infrastructure
you have the region's the AZ's and the
edge locations okay so I mean this is
the full list but really you just need
to remember again for the customer its
data and configuration for AWS its
global infrastructure and hardware okay
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at a to us compliance
program so what is a compliance program
it's a set of internal policies and
procedures of a company to comply with
laws rules and regulations or to uphold
business reputation okay and so we have
a bunch of these cool-looking badges and
the idea here is that if you need to
conform to one of these compliance
programs eight of us has a big list of
them so it makes it easier for you to
adopt cloud computing a two that I want
to point out is HIPAA and PCI so so for
HIPAA that is the Health Insurance
Portability and Accountability Act of
the United States and is a legislation
that provides data privacy and security
provisions for safeguarding medical
information so if you're a hospital
you're going to want to be HIPAA
compliant okay and then you have a PCI
DSS and so this is the payment card
industry data security standard so when
you want to sell things online and you
need to handle a credit card information
you're going to want to be PCI compliant
okay and there's a variety of compliance
programs this is not the full list but
just to give you a taste of what that is
okay all right so I just hopped over
here to the AWS website because I just
wanted to show you the full range of
compliance programs that either Billis
has and if you had to find out if they
had some kind of compliance program how
to investigate that so here I am you can
see we have a bunch of different logos
more than what I was showing you prior
there and you can see that there are
offerings in multiple countries so if we
just scroll down here you can see
there's a lot four of the US we even
have some here for Canada okay which is
where I am asia-pacific Europe okay so
there is a variety of things there all
right now if you wanted to find a little
bit more about any of these
certifications if you just click into
them they'll tell you what it's for and
a lot of additional information okay so
there is a considerable amount of
information here so when you do need to
explore a bit more about compliance
programs definitely check this out now
ax
getting access to the reports for how
eight of us meets those compliance ease
is another story and so that's we're
gonna look at next which is eatable
artifact okay
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at a DuBose artifact
and the purpose of this service is to
really help us determine whether eight
of us is meaning a compliance program
because just because they have the logo
on their website doesn't necessarily
mean that they are compliant you need to
prove that via a very long checklist and
explaining how you are meeting those all
those rules within a compliance program
so if you wanted to get access to that
you actually have to go in a bit of a
round belt way and so any of us has made
a service in order to generate out the
report that shows that they're compliant
so what you do is you would go into a
two ass artifact you choose the package
or artifact you're looking to get it's
going to generate out a PDF and then
within that PDF you have to click a link
which will then get you the actual files
that you that you are seeking okay so
that's what avis artifact is and i'm
gonna show you how to generate an
artifact and get to those files alright
so in this fall along here I'm going to
show you how to use a Debus artifact so
that you can get access to a compliance
report so what I want you to do is go to
the top here to services and we will
type in our to fact if I remember how to
spell it here we just type in art there
we go and so now in artifact we're gonna
get a huge list of all the possible
compliance programs that Abe US has and
so what we'll do is we'll just look for
one so since I'm in Canada let's look
for the the Canada GC partner package
and what you'll do is you'll hit get
this artifact okay and you'll be
presented with a bunch of information
and what we'll do is you should probably
read it and then once you've read it
check that box there and say accept and
download and what that what's that that
is going to do is it's going to download
this PDF document so in order for you to
access the files within this PDF you're
going to have to make sure you have
Adobe Acrobat Reader installed because
it will not work with any other reader
if you're on a Mac like I'm on right now
if you open it up in preview it's not
going to allow you to download those
files but I'm gonna open up Adobe
Acrobat and we're gonna give this a go
alright so I have this document opened
up here in Adobe Acrobat a reader and it
even tells you right off the bat open
the artifact using Adobe Acrobat Reader
other PDF readers are not supported ok
so now that we have this open what we
have to do is follow the instructions
that says click the paperclip paperclip
icon in the top left corner so which is
up here ok and then what it's going to
tell you is a double click the file you
would like to open so there could be a
variety of different files in here
it could be PDFs or CSV Zorich cells but
we'll just go ahead and just double
click this one here and so now we
actually have access to even more
content so now we have an XLS so here I
guess it's just kind of a summary of
what's going on and then within this XLS
file is the file that we're actually
trying to get to so we're gonna go ahead
and open this file ok and here's that
file open there and so you know this is
what we're looking for you can see it's
a very long file ok so the these
documents are gonna vary based on each
compliance program because they're all
different but this is that one and this
is the file that you are trying to get
to that proves that AWS is meeting this
compliance program so there you go hey
this is Andrew Brown from exam pro and
we are looking at Amazon inspector and
the question we are asking here is how
do we prove an ec2 instance is hardened
and so to really understand that
question we need to know what a
hardening is and so hardening is the act
of eliminating as many security risks as
possible ok and so that is what avis
inspector is helping you do so avis
inspector runs a security benchmark
against specific ec2 instances so you
choose which ones you want and you can
run a variety of security benchmarks
ok and so it can run both a network and
hosts assessment so for now
it's checking to see if your if any
ports are open and if they're reachable
to the Internet and then the host is
actually checking the actual OS and any
of the applications there based on the
benchmark or security best practices
that you choose okay so the way
inspector works is that it's gonna
install the eight of us agent on your
ec2 instance which it just does this I
believe through a run command then it's
going to run an assessment for your
assessment target and then it's gonna
then you get to review your findings and
remediate those security issues okay and
so one very popular security benchmark
is the CIS which stands for center of
Internet security and they have over 699
checks and that's what we are going to
be using through our follow along so
let's get to that
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at EWS laughs which
stands for Web Application Firewall and
it's gonna protect us or specifically
our web application from common web
exploits okay so the idea here is you're
gonna write your own rules that are
either going to allow or deny traffic
based on the contents of an HTTP request
and if you didn't want to create your
own rules and you wanted to just use one
from a trusted Avis security partner you
could purchase a one very cheaply in the
eight of us laugh rules marketplace and
so they call it a rule set because it's
a bunch of rules included and generally
of those rule sets will protect you
against the a wasp top ten which are the
most dangerous attacks for web
applications and so whether it's SQL
injection or cross-site scripting or a
host of other ones
again those rule sets are easy to
purchase and protect you against
everything now in order to use laughs it
has to be attached either in front of
cloud front or an application load
balancer and so there you go that is all
you need to know for eight of us laugh
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at EWL shield which
is a managed DDoS protection service
that safeguards applications running on
AWS so just to understand what the
offering for the services we need to
know what a DDoS attack is which stands
for distributed denial of service and
this is a malicious attempt to disrupt
normal traffic by flooding a website
with a large amount of fake traffic okay
and so in order to use a double shield
it's actually already turned on for you
and it's given to all a diverse
customers at no additional charge at
least the shield standard is and so in
order to take advantage of shield you
just have to make sure that you are
routing your traffic through rough 53 or
through cloud front ok now I said that
there is a paint here and that is shield
advanced okay so for shield a standard
this is going to protect you against the
most common DDoS attacks and it's
already turned on automatically for you
and it's available for a lot of
different database services and then you
have a shield advanced which costs
$3,000 per year and you have to pay that
upfront I believe or at least you have
to make a commitment to pay that and
this is going to protect you against
additional types of attacks larger
attacks more sophisticated attacks okay
and it's also going to give you
visibility into this attack so I believe
you get like a dashboard and you also
get 24/7 access to some DDoS experts for
those complex cases
I myself have experienced DDoS and have
paid for such a services shielded ants
so I can definitely understand the value
there and it's only available for a
limited amount of services so it'd be
for roughly 2/3 CloudFront you'll be
there a global accelerator and putting
things in front of or onto an EIP there
ok so that's all there is there and I
probably will just go to the website and
just pull up the big comparison so we
can take a look quick look through it
all right so I've hopped over here to
the aid abuse website to give you a
comparison between shield standard and
shield advanced
and so as we saw earlier shield standard
is turned on for all AWS services where
shield advanced it's going to have the
same coverages of standard but have
additional functionality for of these
specific AWS services okay so if we just
scroll down here you see we have a nice
large comparison the most important
thing to note is that shield advanced is
for mitigating large DDoS attacks so if
someone is specifically targeting you
and sending a lot of traffic your way
you're gonna want to pay for shield
advanced okay another thing about shield
advances that we get that visibility
reporting so we're gonna get a lot more
information as to the nature of these
attacks we're gonna have response team
and support so we're gonna be able to
talk to people to work through that
problem and then we're also gonna get
DDoS cost protection okay so this is
gonna make sure because when you're
getting a lot of traffic couldn't be
hitting these services or f53 CloudFront
you'll be and if you have a lot of
traffic that would cause you to spend a
lot of money so it abyss gives you these
guarantees that you're not gonna be
going overboard and cloths okay so yeah
that's the stuff I wanted to highlight
there for advanced so yeah there we go
hey this is Angie Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the concept of
penetration testing and so it's pen
testing for short so what is pen testing
it's an authorized simulated cyber
attack on a computer system performed to
evaluate the security of the system so
the question here is can you perform pen
test on AWS and the answer is yes there
are some limitations around it and there
are some prohibited activities but you
can definitely do pen testing on AWS so
there are eight services you are
permitted to do pen testing on so you
have ec2 instances nat gateways and
elby's you have RDS you have a cloud
front you have aurora you have api
gateway you have english lambda and
lambda edge you have the lightsail
resources which are just using a variety
of services underneath such as ec2 and
then you have elastic beanstalk so those
are the eight permitted services
and then you have prohibited activities
so you could definitely cannot perform
DDoS attacks you can't do port flooding
you can't do protocol flooding you can't
do requests from flooding anything of
the flooding nature okay you cannot do
DNS and walking so there's that now if
there's something else that you wanted
to do you want me to guess to run a
simulated cyber attack or test you can
submit a request to AWS and they will
reply up to seven days to say whether
you are allowed to do so or not a year
or so ago pentesting wasn't allowed at
all in AWS so they have definitely
opened this up so you can do a lot more
stuff here and just be aware that yes
you can do pen testing on AWS
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at Amazon guard duty
and so the question I want to pose to
you is how do we detect if someone is
attempting to gain access to our eight
of its account or resources and that's
where Amazon guard duty is going to come
into play so guard duty is a threat
detection service that continuously
monitors for malicious suspicious
activity and unauthorized behavior it
uses machine learning to analyze the
following eight of us logs so you have
cloud trail logs your V PC flow logs and
your DNS logs okay and it will alert you
of findings which you can automate an
incident response via cloud watch events
or with a third-party services and just
to add a bit of additional information
if you've ever heard of an IDs or an IPS
those stands for intrusion detection
systems and intrusion protection system
and that is a device or software
application that monitors and network or
systems for malicious activity or policy
violations so that's what Amazon guard
duty is it's an IDs IPS for AWS okay all
right so I just wanted to quickly show
you what findings look like in guard
duty so I have Guardi turned on and I
have a few ec2 instances that are
launched which are just in public V pcs
with with very exposed security groups
and you can see right away that people
are already trying to SSA to brute-force
into my instances because if you do have
instances their public facing with SSH
where you do not restrict the IP to only
your IP you're very
likely to see a brute-force attacks but
you can see here it describes what what
the finding is and a bunch of additional
information about this attack here so
yeah there you go
that's just gardening me there ok this
is Andrew Brown from exam pro and we are
looking at key management service also
known as kms and it is a managed service
that makes it easy for you to create and
control encryption keys used to encrypt
your data and there's three things I
want to know about kms and that is it's
a multi-tenant
HSM HSM stands for hardware security
module and this is a piece of hardware
that's at the end of a data center I
mean there's lots of them but this piece
of hardware is specifically designed for
storing keys within memory so they're
never written to disk and that piece of
hardware is extremely secure it's
multi-tenant in the sense that there's
other customers that are utilizing that
same piece of hardware and you all are
virtually isolated from each other via
software ok and the other two points I
want you to know is that many abus
services integrate with kms to encrypt
your data with a simple checkbox so in
this screenshot here we have RDS where
we were enabling encryption and that is
using kms ok so a lot of services have
that checkbox and then you just choose
the key from kms and kms uses envelope
encryption okay and so envelope
encryption we have an example down below
and the idea here is you might have a
you have a key that encrypts your data
but what is going to protect your data
key from from being encrypted ok so
that's what we're doing is that we're
encrypting the key that we use to
encrypt our data with and that's why
it's called envelope encryption because
it's like putting your key within an
envelope so people can't see that key
alright and yeah that is kms
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we were looking at Amazon may see
which is a fully managed service that
continuously monitors s3 data access
activity for anomalies and generates
detail alerts when it detects risks of
unauthorized access or inadvertently
data leaks so that was a very long
sentence so if you weren't following
along I wasn't either so just to
reiterate Amazon may see it the idea is
here is that you put data in your s3
bucket and that data can be it could be
sensitive data such as credit card
numbers or personally identify
identifiable information or it could be
health record information and so what
Amazon may see does using the power of
machine learning and also analyzing your
cloud trail logs it's going to detect
that sense of data and whether that data
has a risk of being compromised or
exposed okay so if you put a file full
of credit cards in plain text and you
upload it to your rescue bucket Amazon
Mesa is gonna say hey we found some
credit cards and it's plain text you
should probably I don't know encrypt
this and and archive it and make sure
nobody has access to it okay so that's
the role of Amazon may see now Maci has
a variety of lurtz and this kind of
gives you an idea the kind of things
that can detect so ransomware someone
trying to lock you out your data and
make you pay for it privilege escalation
so someone trying to get access to stuff
that they're not supposed to identity
enumeration somebody that is trying to
enumerate over the list of stuff that
you have to figure out what they can
steal information loss if you've lost
data credit credentials lost so if you
have stored credentials there and they
were lost so there's a bunch of alerts
that it can alert you on the other thing
that it can do is it will identify your
most at-risk users which could lead to a
compromised okay so if you have some on
your team and you know they're just
having very poor practices and accessing
sensitive files very often they're gonna
rank it based on this these badges okay
and it's funny because you think bronze
would be the worst user but platinum is
actually the worst user so the the nicer
the badge is the worse this user is and
you have to give them that attention
okay but anyway that is what Amazon
ACS hey this is Angie Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at security
groups versus and knackles okay and so
these are both used to act as firewalls
within your V PC but the utility of
these are slightly different okay
so just knowing the difference here is a
good thing to cover especially when we
are in the security section here so
looking at security groups they act as a
firewall at the instance level whereas
knackles act as a firewall at the subnet
level so in that diagram you can see
that all those instances are contained
within a security group and they can
span multiple subnets whereas the nack
will sit in front of the subnets and
they're gonna control access in and out
from subnets okay now security groups
implicitly deny all traffic and so you
have to create allow rules to get access
to things okay and so that's both for
inbound and outbound okay so the idea is
that if you wanted to open up port 22 so
you could SSH into an instance that's an
allow rule you would create on that
security group now with knackles you can
allow N and deny rules okay but the real
utility here with knackles is that you
can block a specific IP address known
for abuse okay because you can have deny
rules and you can say exactly I want to
deny exactly this IP address so the
reason you can't do this with security
groups is that because implicitly denies
everything in order for you to do to
deny a single IP and allow everything
else
imagine all the IP addresses in the
world right you'd have to create allow
rules for everything from those IP
addresses and just exclude that one IP
address which is like almost impossible
so for knackles the best use case here
is again block a specific IP address
known for abuse okay so hopefully that
helps you understand screw groups versus
knackles and that's what we need to know
here
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at database VPN which
stands for virtual private network and
what this service does is it lets you
establish a secure and private tunnel
from your network or device to the ADA
best global network and so it comes in
two variations we have site to site VPN
and a client VPN so what is the
difference here so for site to site this
is where you securely connect
on-premises networks or a branch office
to your ADA bits of EPC and then for the
client VPN this is where you securely
connect users to ADA bus or on-premise
networks ok so the idea here is that you
are for site to site you're connecting
an entire office or network to AWS and
the client is just like imagine you have
some employees and they have laptops and
they're or they're working from home and
you want them to connect them to the ADA
best network that's what you're going to
be using so just know that you can do
that and it is a private tunnel and it
is secure and that there are these two
variations here
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we were doing a bit of variation
study and we're gonna look at services
that have cloud in the name because I
want you to know that even though they
have similar names they're completely
different services and I just don't want
you to get mixed up with these things so
we're gonna learn about all the services
that start with clouds starting with
cloud formations of cloud formation is
infrastructure as code and it sets up
services via templating scripts such as
Gamal or JSON it is used for
provisioning lots of resources on AWS
okay moving on to cloud trail this is
for logging all API calls between a to
the services so I always say it's about
who you can blame okay then on to cloud
front cloud front is a content
distribution network it creates a cache
copy of your website and copies that
content to servers located near people
trying to download your website okay
it's going to be using edge locations to
do that then moving on to cloud Watch
which is a collection of multiple
services ok and so starting with cloud
watch logs any custom data or
data so memory usage rails logs or nginx
logs then you have cloud watch metrics
and these are metrics that are based off
of the logs I like to think of metrics
as graphs because that's how they are
represented so it's like your log data
so like if you want to memory usage
graphed over time that's cloud watch
metrics okay then you have cloud watch
events and this is triggers triggers an
event based on a condition so you could
have a condition where every hour it
takes a snapshot of the server and these
can be based off of metrics or or log
data okay then you have cloud watch
alarms and these trigger notifications
based on metrics then you have cloud
watch dashboard and this creates
visualizations based on metrics the last
one here on our list is cloud search and
it is a search engine so let's say you
had an e-commerce website and you wanted
to add a search bar to search across all
products on your website unlike just or
just like amazon.com that's what you
would use okay hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and now I just want to
cover services that have connect in the
name alright and so there are three
services will connect they are totally
all unrelated but let's learn a little
bit about these three so we can
distinguish them ok so the first on our
list is Direct Connect and it is a
dedicated fiber optics connection from
your data center to AWS so this is ideal
for large enterprises that own their own
data center and they need to have
insanely fast connection directly to AWS
if you need to secure these connections
you can also apply a VPN it was VPN on
top of Direct Connect okay next is
Amazon Connect and this is basically a
call center in the cloud so you get a
toll-free number it can accept inbound
and outbound calls and you can automate
automate like a phone system within it
last night our list here is media
connect and it is the new version of
elastic transcoder it converts videos to
different video types so if you have a
thousand videos and you need to
transcode them into different video
formats then or if you had to apply like
a watermark or insert in an introduction
video this is what you would use okay
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro I
just quickly want to do a comparison
between elastic transcoder and media
convert the both these services
transcode videos so it's a little bit
confusing but I'll just tell you a bit
of the story here so elastic transcoder
is the old way it was the first service
that came out that could Transco videos
into streaming formats and you have a
video in one format and you want to turn
it into another format and so any of us
came up with a number of servers called
ibis elemental media convert and it is
the new way of transcoding videos I
don't know if they rebuilt it from
scratch but it has the exact same use
case except it has additional features
that elastic transcoder cannot do so you
can overlay images you can insert video
clips you can do extracts for caption
data and has a much more robust qi so at
one point i believe that people were
still using elastic transcoder because
it just had better integration with the
Atos api but I'm pretty sure media
convert has caught up and anytime you're
using elastic transcoder AV bus is
always telling you hey go use media
convert okay but elastic transcoder is
still around cuz I'm sure they have
customers that are pretty much used to
it and these things are priced pretty
much the same okay so you're not gonna
really save money by using elastic
transcoder but there is the comparison
for you hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and I want to just do a quick
matchup here of SNS versus sqs because
these are easy services to get mixed up
because they both have something to do
with messaging and they both are used
for application integration so they
connect apps together so let's look at
SNS first so SNS which stands for simple
notification service it is using pub/sub
which is publisher subscriber messaging
model and so with it it passes along
messages whereas with simple queue
service it is a messaging service but
it's all about queuing up messages okay
and so with simple notification service
it's just passing them along whereas sqs
you can get a guaranteed of deliver
okay now going back to s and s s NS
sends notifications to subscribers of
topics via multiple protocols so it can
use HTTP email it can also send it to SQ
s you can also send text messages and it
can send to lambda as well there which I
just don't have listed okay
where as simple q service you place
messages in a queue and the and you have
applications pull the queue using the
AWS SDK all right back on the s and s so
SNS is generally used for sending plain
text emails I really got to emphasize
that because it cannot do HTML emails
which is triggered via other a table
services so the best example is building
alarm so if you've ever had a billion
alarm and it's been triggered it's going
to send you a plain text email okay so
that's the exact use case their SNS does
have the ability to retry sending in the
case for HTTP so that's when you are
sending web hooks okay so that there is
some kind of retry functionality there
now moving over to sqs so sqs can retain
a message for up to 14 days they can
send them in sequential order or in
parallel they can ensure only one
message is sent they can ensure messages
are delivered at least once okay and so
there's the comparison there and just
the last part here so SNS is really good
for web hooks simple internal emails or
triggering line to functions and we have
sqs is really good for delay tasks and
queuing up emails all right if you
needed a comparison of other similar
services for SNS if you've ever heard of
pusher or PubNub that is basically what
SNS is and for SQS if you ever heard of
RabbitMQ or sidekick that's what sqs is
there you go
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam row
and I want to do a comparison here
between inspector and trust advisor
because both of these services have a
security component involved in them and
so they are easy to mix up
okay so Amazon inspector it is designed
to audit ec2 instances so you can audit
a single instance there all the
instances within your region and and so
it would run a script which would then
run against a security checklist it will
come back and report to you what checks
have passed or failed so there is one
very popular benchmark by the CIS which
will do 699 checks ok and the other side
we have trusted advisor and trusted
advisor doesn't generate PDF report it
probably is a way to export a CSV or
something but it's not like something
that is promoted with trusted advisor
but it gives you a holistic view of
recommendations across multiple service
services and best practices and so it
has a whole section on just security
okay so tell you something like hey you
should really enable MFA on your root
account so inspector is really just
about ec2 instances and and making them
secure or hardened and Trust advisor is
all about multiple dangerous services
and security practices ok
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro I
just want to quickly cover the three
different types of load balancers so you
have an idea of their use case so before
application network load balancer
existed all there was was elastic load
bouncer and now it's been renamed to
classic load bouncer and it basically
does the job of both application network
load bouncer but it has a way for your
features and it works slightly different
ok so classic blue bouncer does not use
target groups and it's intended for
applications that were built with the
ec2 classic network in mind okay
so generally you do not want to launch a
classical investor you still can but
you're going to want to use application
and network load bouncer because they
are specialized for their individual use
case so for the
Asian loads load bouncer it's working at
layer seven layer seven is the
application layer so it's dealing with
HTTP and HTTPS traffic okay and so if
you're running a web application this is
what you're going to want to use it has
some advanced routing rules so it allows
you to get more usability out of your
load bouncer so prior to this if you
needed a load bouncer per subdomain
you'd have to launch a load bouncer for
each one but now you with routing rules
you can route all subdomains to the
single load bouncer and make sure that
it goes to the right instances that you
want to target okay
and so with application load bouncer you
are able to attach a laugh laugh stands
for Web Application Firewall and so
since its application load bouncer and
web application firewalls just for
applications it makes sense why you
would be able to attach it okay now on
to the network load bouncer this
operates at layer 4 which is the
transport layer and it's dealing with IP
protocol data so this is where you are
dealing with TCP and TLS traffic where
extreme performance is required so think
video games think real-time so think
about handling millions of requests per
second while maintaining ultra-low
latency ok it's also optimized for
sudden and volatile traffic patterns so
that is another advantage there ok and
then all these load balancers you can
attach the Amazon certification manager
so you can apply SSL certificate so you
have HTTP traffic ok
so there you go hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro I'm just gonna do a quick
match up of SNS vs SES and so these two
services are easy to confuse because
they both send emails ok so let's learn
the difference so SNS which stands for
simple notification service it is a
really intended for practical use cases
and internal you cases when it comes to
sending emails all right so with SNS you
can send notifications to subscribers of
topics if you have multiple protocols so
we're not just limited to email but we
have HTTP email sqs SMS and it can also
do lambdas all right on the other side
we have
SDS which stands for simple email
service and this is really utilized for
professional emails marketing emails all
right and so it basically is a
cloud-based email service have you ever
heard of SendGrid that is what SES is
all right so going back to S&S SMS is
generally used for sending in plain text
emails which is triggered via other a to
the services and the best example here
is building alarms okay so if you ever
had a billion alarm and it's been
triggered it would send you an SMS plain
text email it's an ugly email but it
does the job okay over on to SES SES
sends HTML emails and can also send
plate-up plain text emails
whereas SNS cannot do that so SNS cannot
send HTML email so if you want something
that's going to look good you're gonna
have to use SES SES it can also receive
inbound emails SES can create email
templates you can use a custom domain
name or a name name for your email and
you can monitor your email reputation so
there's a lot of other stuff that is
going on there with SES so you can see
it's really optimized for emails so yeah
there you go so that is the comparison
there hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
pro I just want to do a quick comparison
between artifact and inspector and the
reason why is that they both can pile up
PDF reports so that is where some
confusion can can happen so I just want
to clarify the difference between these
two services so artifact is all about
why should an enterprise trust a TOS so
does ABS meet specific compliance
frameworks such as sock or PCI and
inspector is all about how do we know
this ec2 instance is secure can you
prove it and so it runs a script that
analyzes your ec2 instance and then
generates out a PDF report telling you
which security checks have passed okay
so that is the difference between these
two services but just be aware that they
both compile out PDFs
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and I congratulate you for making your
way through the journey content and so
now all that's left to do is to do some
practice exam questions and if you're
scoring all right that means you're
ready to go book your exam which I'll
show you here in the next section
shortly okay so there you go all right
so now it's time to book our exam and
it's always a bit of a trick to actually
find where this page is so if you were
to search aid of a certification and go
here all right and then maybe go to the
training overview and then click get
started it's going to take you to a
Debus dot training and this is where you
are going to a register to take the exam
so in the top right corner we are going
to have to go ahead and go sign-in and I
already have an account so I'm just
gonna go and log in with my account
there so I'm just gonna hit sign in
there okay and we're just gonna have to
provide our credentials here so I'm just
gonna go ahead and fill mine in and I
will see you on the other side and just
show you the rest of it here all right
so now we are in the training and
certification portal so at the top we
have a table stop training and to get to
booking our exam we got to go to
certification here and then we're gonna
have to go to our account and we're
going to be using the certain metrics
third-party service that actually
manages the AVA certifications so we're
gonna go to our certain metrics account
here and now we can go ahead and
schedule our exam so we're going to
schedule a new exam and down below we're
going to get a full list of exams here
so it used to just be psi and so now
they all have psi Pearson VUE these are
just a network of training centers where
you can actually go take and sit the
exam for the CCP you can actually take
it from home now it's the only
certification you can take from home it
is a monitored exam but for the rest
they have to be done at a data center
and so I'm just gonna show you how to
book it either with psi or a Pearson VUE
here and again they have a different
data center so if you do not find a data
center in your area I'll just go give
Pearson VUE a look so that you can
actually go book that exam so let's go
take a look at an exam so maybe we will
book the professional here so I'm just
going to open this in a tab and open
that a tab and we're going to review how
we can book it here through these two
portals so let's take a look at psi this
is the one I'm most familiar with okay
because Pearson VUE wasn't here the last
time I checked but so here you can see
the duration and the confirmation number
you want to definitely make sure you're
taking the right exam sometimes there
are similar exams like the old ones that
will be in here so just be a hundred
percent sure before you go ahead and do
that and go and schedule your exam and
so it's even telling you that there is
more than one available here and that's
fine so we'll sit continue okay and then
from here we're gonna wait here and
we're gonna select our language okay and
then we get to choose our data center so
the idea is you want to try to find a
data center near you so if I typed in
Toronto here so we'll get enter a city
in here like Toronto I don't know why I
thinks I'm over here and I'm just going
to hit Toronto here and we're gonna
search for exam centers okay and then we
are going to have a bunch of over here
so the closest one in Toronto is up here
so I'm gonna click one all right and
it's gonna show me the available times
that I can book so there's not a lot of
times this week generally you have to it
has to be like two three days ahead
every time I booked exam it's never been
the next day but here we actually have
one it's gonna vary based on the test
center that you have here we're gonna go
ahead here and this one only lets you do
Wednesdays and Thursdays so if we had
the Thursday here at 5:00 p.m. okay and
then we would choose that and we would
continue okay and then we would hit
continue again all right and so the
booking has been created and in order to
finalize it we just have to pay that it
is in USD dollars okay so you'd have to
just go and fill that out and once
that's filled out and you pay it then
you are ready to go sit that exam so
that's how we do with psi and then we're
gonna go take a look over at Pearson VUE
so I'm just gonna go ahead and clear
this because I'm not serious about
booking an exam right now okay and we'll
go take a look how we do it with Pearson
good so here we are in the Pearson VUE
Section two book and you first need to
choose your preferred language I can
choose English because that's what I'm
most comfortable with and we're gonna
just hit next here and the next thing
it's going to show us is the price and
we'll say schedule this exam alright and
now we can proceed to scheduling okay so
I'll just proceed to scheduling it's
giving me a lot of superfluous option
alright okay hello let's go and here we
can see locations in Toronto okay so
here are our test centers and we do
actually have a bit of variation here so
you can see there are some different
offerings you might also see the same
data center so I can choose this one
here okay and it lets you select up to
three to compare at the availability so
sure we will select three and we will
hit next okay we'll just wait a little
bit here all right okay hello let's go
and now we are just going to choose when
we want to take that exam there so we do
have those three options to compare and
so you know I just choose that 11 time
okay and so then we would see that
information and we could proceed to
checkout
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are at the end here so I hope you
sat your exam and you pass and when you
do I definitely want to hear your
feedback
I do appreciate any kind of criticisms
you do have of the the course curriculum
here of any regards and definitely be
sure to share with me your success on
social media so whether it's LinkedIn
Twitter Instagram I want to hear from
you okay